[musique]
Alain Jueter, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
Nous sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement ?
Moi je m'appelle Alain Juyet. J'ai je
suis fort âgé parce que j'ai j'ai 79
ans. Donc c'est ça commence à faire pas
mal.
J'ai fait une carrière qui est commencé
dans les services, enfin comme officier
dans les services. Puis je suis passé
dans le privé en travaillant dans plein
d'entreprises françaises et étrangères
comme dirigeant. Ensuite, je suis parti
de nouveau dans l'administration comme
directeur du renseignement à la DGSE
puis au responsable l'intelligence
économique au SGDN auprès du premier
ministre. Et puis ensuite, ben ces
dernières années, j'ai été dans un
cabinet d'avocat d'affaires et en même
temps, j'ai géré un certain nombre de
problèmes et d'associations
dont une qui s'occupait de la sécurité,
les directeurs de sécurité des
entreprises et l'autre qui est
l'accadémie de l'intelligence économique
où je retrouvais un peu mes amours.
On a décidé on a décidé de vous refaire
venir aujourd'hui parce que votre
expérience, votre regard et et surtout
notre communauté vous adore.
Votre dernière interview, c'est plus de
2 millions de vues.
Oui. Et
et
et c'est extraordinaire.
Vous avez eu des retours un peu de ça de
votre première
Ah moi j'ai été quand je suis sorti de
mon interview et après 2 heures plus de
2h d'interview, je me suis dit ça
marchera jamais. les gens n'écoutent pas
2 heures d'interview.
Et puis j'ai commencé à comprendre, non
pas par les chiffres qu'on me donnait,
mais j'ai commencé à comprendre la
réalité quand un jour, quelques mois
plus tard, mais quelques mois plus
tardin, j'étais en train de remonter à
pied les laavenue de la grande armée là
pour aller à ma voiture et il y a un
camion, vraiment un camion de livraison
mais en mauvais état qui s'est arrêté.
Un type qui est descendu du camion, le
chauffeur qui est venu me voir et qui me
dit "Vous êtes à l'inju".
Je suis dit oui. Et il me dit "Je vous
ai vu sur 5, c'est formidable, il faut
continuer." Et alors là, j'étais je me
suis rendu compte de la puissance des
réseaux sociaux parce que j'avais jamais
imaginé que je pourrais me faire comme
ça arrêter gentiment, très gentiment. Et
depuis alors j'ai eu j'ai eu des
quantités de fois où les gens m'ont
m'ont parlé en me disant "Je vous ai vu
sur Syer Viiew, je vous ça m'a beaucoup
intéressé." Donc, je me suis rendu
compte qu'en définitive avec cette
émission euh
j'avais pu toucher grâce grâce à Simu,
j'avais pu toucher des quantités de gens
que je n'aurais jamais touché autrement.
Et donc il y avait un vrai public pour
des choses à la fois très sérieuses mais
sur lesquelles on peut parler à fond.
c'est-à-dire sur lesquels on peut
s'exprimer non pas en 30 secondes comme
souvent sur les chaînes de télévision,
mais au contraire en essayant
d'expliquer vraiment ce qui se passe. Et
je moi qui personnellement je suis très
proche euh de ceux qui croient que c'est
le dessous des cartes qu'il faut
appréhender beaucoup plus que la surface
des choses ou l'écume des jours comme
dit comme dit certains, je pense que là
c'est une c'est c'était et puis
maintenant j'en suis convaincu une
formidable opportunité pour ça que je
reviens ravi. Alors, c'est parfait. On
va commencer avec notre premier sujet.
On va essayer de parler géopolitique, de
finances, de terrorisme et comme on fait
d'habitude. Sauf que là, on va parler
Afghanistan,
d'accord ?
La débale de l'armée américaine en
Afghanistan.
Quelle est votre lecture et quelles sont
les conséquences auxquelles on on doit
s'attendre ?
Il y a il y a plusieurs choses dans la
guerre en Afghanistan parce que il y a
quand on regarde toute l'histoire de la
guerre, au départ, il y a une décision
politique hein d'envahir l'Afghanistan
pour punir en définitive Al-Qaïda de
l'affaire du 11 septembre. Ça c'est
première première version.
Mais très vite après pour justifier en
se rendant compte que la guerre c'est
pas si facile que ça. Penladen il a
réussi à échapper un torabora il réussit
à échapper à l'encerclement
ça se passe pas et les Américains à ce
moment-là vont faire ce qui est
classique maintenant et ben nous aussi
on connaît bien la méthode. Ils vont
faire une guerre qui vont le justifier
non plus par la par la lutte contre
Al-Qaïda mais par la la nécessité de
transformer un pays pour en faire un
pays moderne démocratique et autres. On
fait la même chose en Afrique nous. Bon
le problème
c'est que c'est mauvais.
Est-ce que vous pouvez redresser un peu
votre micro ?
Ouais magnifique. Super l'ingénieur
désolé de vous avoir coupé. Continuez.
Pas de problème. Oui. Donc c'est le 2uxè
temps, c'est qu'on va donc et on va on
va justifier une guerre pour des motifs
sur lesquel on pourra venir qui sont
très discutables.
Pourquoi ? Parce que quand on regarde
toutes les guerres qui ont été menées
depuis 1945,
que c'est ça qu'il faut voir, les
guerres qu'ont mené les États-Unis
depuis 1945, il dans le meilleur des
cas, il y a eu un cessé le feu, c'est la
Corée, hein, avec la séparation entre la
Corée du Nord et la Corée du Sud. Bon,
mais partout ailleurs, hein, ils ont
perdu à part, il faut bien le dire quand
même, l'invasion de Panama et celle de
la barbade. Enfin, c'est pas c'est pas
sérieux quoi, hein. Mais en dehors de
ces deux petits cas-là, ils ont perdu
toutes les guerres qu'ils ont faites. Et
c'est ça qu'il faut se poser comme
question. Comment se fait-il qu'une
puissance avec une puissance avec une
dirait une capacité militaire aussi
importante ? Hein ? Il faut quand même
pas oublier que les États-Unis, c'est en
gros hein, c'est 760 milliards de
dollars dans la défense quand les deuxè
les Chinois sont à 260
hein et le trè il est à peu près à une
centaine de milliards et nous on est à
50 enfin un peu moins hein. Donc on voit
bien la différence quoi. Et bien malgré
cette puissance colossale ils ne savent
pas ils n'arrivent pas à gagner les
guerres. Ça, je crois que c'est
fondamental parce que du même coup,
ils essaient de justifier la guerre par
un faux prétexte. On va transformer le
pays, on sait que ça marche pas.
Ensuite, deuxème temps, il livre cette
guerre et elle ne Et évidemment, il n'y
arrive pas. Il tente toutes les
solutions. On a eu en Afghanistan, il y
a eu des gens remarquables. Petraus, le
général Petraus
était un type absolument remarquable
qui a eu qui avait des idées pour lutter
contre les guerrias, contre tout ça en
s'inspirant dehors du français hein du
de bouquin français et il a essayé de
faire des choses intéressantes et
intues. Mais ça n'a pas marché. Rien n'a
marché. En définitive, une fois de plus,
les guerres d'envahissement colonial, on
ne sait pas les gagner. Les Français
d'ailleurs aussi, hein, c'est pareil, on
les perd tout. Alors, c'est la deuxème
volée. Alors, après, il y a eu un trè 3è
étape, je dirais, c'est quand les
Américains sont rendus compte que
c'était la guerre qui était devenue la
plus longue de leur histoire,
qu'ils avaient des pertes quand même
significatives.
H Et donc, comment en sortir ? Il voyait
bien qu'il gagnerait pas donc comment en
sortir et d'aut alors ça on l'a vu
arriver avec Obama était déjà un peu
branlant je dirais et on l'a vu, on l'a
vu très clairement avec Trump. Trump qui
a dit "On ramène les boys aux
États-Unis, c'est-à-dire on ne veut plus
faire la guerre parce qu'il a lui il a
compris que les gens en avaient assez,
les Américains en avaient assez, que ça
coûtait très cher et qu'il les gagnait
pas. Donc quand on fait un constat
pareil, on dit vaut mieux arrêter."
Donc il a lancé l'idée d'où les pour
parler de Doa, la discussion avec eux et
en se disant bon puisqu'on est en face
de nous les taliban, pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas négocier avec eux puisque
c'est les plus forts ils sont en face de
nous.
Il faut dire que ils sont arrivés là
parce que tout l'argent qui a été
déversé pour faire une armée afghane n'a
servi à rien. Tout l'argent qui a été
déversé vers les chefs afghans pour
monter un gouvernement et tout. On est
arrivé à une corruption majeure.
D'ailleurs, à part un ou deux, tous les
grands responsables afghans ont quitté
le pays avant que les Américains sortent
de Kaboule, hein. Mais ils sont partis
avec beaucoup d'argent. Et on pourrait
se demander d'ailleurs si ceuxlà il faut
les laisser effectivement vivre
tranquillement leur vie avec tout ce
qu'ils ont pu prendre là-bas parce que
là on est dans les biens malakiquis pour
reprendre une habitude française hein
clairement hein le donc Trump avait a
son a discuté à Doa et a dit on va
arrêter bon donc les talibans ont
compris qu'ils avaient gagné
je pense que l'erreur ensuite qu'a fait
Biden
ça a était d'annoncer une date exacte
pour le départ
parce qu'à partir du moment où on donne
une date exacte pour un départ, bah les
autres en face, il disent ce soir-là, on
est les maîtres.
Donc comme la date était très très
rapprochée, contrairement à ce qui était
prévu où il avait été prévu, c'estd que
les talibans progressivement province
par province allaiit se rapprocher de
Kabou, ben ils l'ont fait à marche
forcée et ils l'ont fait d'autant plus
facilement que l'armée afghane, ben elle
jouait sa peau. Les types, ils voulaient
pas rester pour se faire tuer, ça sert à
rien. Il préférait partir. Donc tout le
monde a abandonné tout le monde
et les Américains alors en plus dans
cette affaire
de Biden et Yandy on s'en va.
On voit bien que l'armée américaine qui
en avait par-dessus la tête a est partie
encore plus vite que prévu, hein. Et la
seule chose qu'on peut les recréditer,
contrairement à l'image qui est donnée
un peu partout, qui a été donné un peu
partout, c'est que à l'aéroport de
Kaboule, à la sortie, ils ont réussi
quelque chose d'incroyable. C'est un
pont aérien qui a sorti plus de 350000
personnes et ça c'est des ils ont sorti
des Afghans en en énorme quantité. Là on
peut pas Alors là je crois que vraiment
euh c'est triste parce que on a de
l'image de Kabou que des gens qui
veulent grimper dans l'avion et puis des
qui tombent d'ailleurs d'un avion en vol
hein. Et on ne voit pas qu'en définitive
les Américains ont sorti en très peu de
jours près de 400000 personnes de de de
Kabou. Ça c'est quelque chose qu'il
faudra qu'on regarde. Ça veut dire que
par rapport à l'Indochine par exemple,
ils ont su organiser leur ils ont su
organiser
ça leur a servi de leçon.
Exactement. Et ils ont réussi à mettre
le pont aérien qu'il fallait pour sortir
les gens. Il faut dire que les talibans
ont été très coopératifs contrairement
là aussi à ce qu'on a dit parce qu'il y
a beaucoup de choses qui ont été dit.
Ils ont été très coopératifs pour une
bonne et simple raison. c'est que les
talibans dans cette affaire aujourd'hui
ont besoin de tout le monde. Ils ont
besoin d'argent de la part des pays du
dénonneur du golf. Ils ont besoin
d'argent de tout le monde. Ils avaient
besoin de l'appui des Américains parce
qu'il y a aussi des aides
internationales qui sont données à
l'Afghanistan. Et donc il n'avaient
aucun intérêt à à apparaître plus
mauvais ou je l'ai même dire comme ils
sont hein. Ils ont au contraire ils sont
donnés une image de gentil. Alors, il
faut quand même pas exagérer parce que
quand on voit le gouvernement qui a été
créé après, on voit qu'en réalité c'est
une façade mais que derrière on est bel
et bien devant un gouvernement qui va
fonctionner comme on fonctionnait il y a
de siècles en France ou trois siècles en
France.
Question internet, j'en profite. Le
départ d'Afghanistan est-il est une
décision unilatérale de Trump ou bien
également une évidence du point de vue
du Pentagone ? Est-ce que c'est Trump
qui a décidé ou le Pentagone ?
Les deux. Les deux. Les deux. Trump.
Trump avant avant même qu'il soit élu
hein, personment j'avais eu l'occasion
d'en parler à cette époque-là.
Avant même qu'il soit élu, Trump disait
déjà que son programme c'était de sortir
de toutes ces guerres qui coûtaient des
fortunes un peu partout au Moyen-Orient,
en Irak, en Syrie et partout, hein, en
Afghanistan. Il voulait sortir de toutes
les guerres parce qu'il disait "Ça ne
sert à rien, on ne les gagne pas et en
plus ce ne sont pas nos ennemis."
Parce que c'est là Trump la le grand la
grande différence entre Trump et les
autres, c'est que Trump a dit "Nous
n'avons qu'un ennemi, c'est la Chine.
Avant, il y avait les Russes pour Obama,
il y avait les Russes Biden, il y avait
les Russes avec l'Ukraine, hein, parce
que Biden a été au cœur de l'affaire
ukrainienne. Donc, il y avait il y avait
toute une tendance opposition avec les
Russes, opposition au Moyen-Orient
contre il y en il y avait des des
oppositions partout. Trump a dit c'est
fini, on a un seul ennemi, c'est la
Chine. Il a commencé à taper avec tous
les moyens économiques qui pouvait et on
rapatrie les boys à la maison parce
qu'ils ont autre chose à faire qu'à se
faire tuer. Et derrière Biden,
contrairement à ce que les gens
pensaient, parce que là aussi quand
Biden a été élu, on a tout le monde a
dit "Ah, c'est pas Trump". Mais tous
ceux qui connaissaient le dossier
américain savaient très bien que sur le
plan international et en particulier sur
le plan militaire, Biden allait être
exactement dans la ligne de Trump et il
l' et ce qui montre bien que le
Pentagone qui est très puissant le
complexe militaroindustriel américain ou
l'Amérique profonde comme on dit là-bas
deep state hein et bien était tout à
fait d'accord en disant il faut qu'on
parte.
J'en profite pour passer aussi une
question internet. Que pensez-vous de
l'usage démesuré des sociétés privées
américaines dans la guerre en
Afghanistan ? Alors ça c'est un autre
problème.
Je pense que nous sommes aujourd'hui on
est dans un problème majeur, c'est que
les les États ont de plus en plus de mal
à faire la guerre parce que les
populations des États concernés n'ont
pas envie de voir leurs gens se faire
tuer dehors.
Donc on le voit bien. Regardez en
France, on a eu on a on a encore on a
encore avec Barcane, avec on a en
Afrique, on a régulièrement des morts.
Bon, chaque mort est un problème
aujourd'hui.
Quand on a fait des guerres comme 14 18
ou 39 45 ou d'autres ou les guerres
napoléoniennes,
un mort, 10 morts ou 100 morts ou 1000
morts ou 10000 morts dans la journée, ça
ne comptait pas.
La chair à canon.
Mais oui, c'était de la c'était une
autre mentalité.
hein. Maintenant, la vie des individus
dans une nation, nationaux, ça compte.
Alors, comment font les militaires et
comment font les politiques ? et bien on
va sous-traiter la faire la guerre à des
sociétés privées
et on va mais pour ça on va leur donner
de l'armement, on va leur donner du
pouvoir avec le risque bien entendu que
ces sociétés privées qui ne sont pas des
armées, même si hein la plupart d'entre
elles sont composées de militaires à 99
% et on ne on n'est jamais sûr que ça ne
tourne pas mal. Souvenez-vous en Irak
avec G4S par exemple hein où le hein et
les autres qui ont ils ont été pris en
train de faire des massacre ce qui est
quand même pas bon. Mais il faut se
souvenir que lorsqu'on a fait la guerre
dans les Balkans, on l'oublie
aujourd'hui.
Et quand on a attaqué la Serbie en
disant que la Bosnie voulait son
indépendance,
qui était derrière et qui organisait les
troubles
en Bosnie et dans la zone, c'était MPRI,
une société militaire privée américaine
et qui appuyait les dirigeants de Bosnie
qu'on a vu après devenir les patrons de
la Bosnie actuelle et pour la plupart
d'entre eux qui viennent d'être mis en
examen pour des crimes de guerre.
Donc on voit bien quand on n'est pas
militaire, on ne risque plus les
poursuites de la justice et on peut s'en
sortir.
Et la guerre par proxy, ce qu'on appelle
la guerre par proxy, c'est
Oui.
Vous pouvez nous expliquer ce que c'est
la guerre par proxy ?
Bah justement, la guerre par proxy,
c'est qu'on va essayer de on va essayer
de faire la guerre mais en aucun cas
qu'on y soit mêlé directement.
Alors si je fais la guerre avec des
sociétés militaires privées, bah c'est
pas moi qui l'a fait la guerre, c'est
les sociétés militaires privé et s'il y
a des choses qui sont pas bien, c'est
pas moi. Donc je m'en lave les mains,
hein. Une autre solution, c'est de
financer des gens d'un autre pays ou
d'encourager sous une forme ou sous une
autre un autre pays pour faire à faire
la guerre
dans le pays concerné et de manière à se
pouvoir dire c'est pas nous.
C'est le pays qui a décidé de faire la
guerre.
Quand on entend entend que le
gouvernement américain a 60000
contractuels
Oui.
censé faire une une guerre sur internet
pour influencer l'opinion publique.
Oui, c'est ce qu'ils ont dit. la le les
Chinois les Chinois ont sensiblement la
même chose sont sensiblement la même
chose les Français on sait pas bien.
Est-ce que ça peut représenter un risque
qu'il y ait de l'astroturfing
financé par des pays extérieurs en
France et qu'est-ce que la France doit
faire contre ce type de proxy ? On
s'éloigne un peu du sujet. Non non mais
c'est un vrai sujet hein.
C'est un vrai sujet parce que
l'utilisation de appelons ça ben de
mercenaires parce que c'est ça c'est pas
autre chose c'est les mercenaires
modernes. l'Empire de Rome, pour revenir
à l'histoire, l'empire de Rome quand il
a eu des difficultés, quand il était,
c'est c'est intéressant à ce point de
vue là d'ailleurs he quand il a eu
commencé à avoir des difficultés les
Légions romaines et ben elles étaient
plus y vaillantes qu'avant. Les gens ne
voulaient plus se faire tuer parce
qu'ils s'étaient enrichis, vivaient bien
et donc il voulait plus faire la guerre.
On a pris des mercenaires
et ça a été le début de la fin.
Donc il faut se poser la question avant
avant tout de se dire quand je délègue
un pouvoir régalien qui est celui de
faire la guerre à des gens de
l'extérieur
quel qu'il soit que ce soit des États
auquels je sous-traite la guerre ou des
sociétés militaires privées
partis politiques
ou des partis politiques he que qui
organisent des troubles internes et qui
vont on l'a vu hein euh on l'a vu aussi
avec par exemple sur le moyen-orient
avec le printemps arabe he le printemps
arabe Ça a été manipulé d'un bout à
l'autre hein avec plus avec beaucoup
d'échecs là encore un échec total on
peut dire attraper en Égypte je crois
bien. Mais bon
oui mais c'est mais tout ça tout cette
tout ça c'est sont des en définitive
c'est une nouvelle forme de faire la
guerre.
Ah j'ouvre une parenthèse sur sur
Oui.
Est-ce aussi une stimulation ? Est-ce
que le fait de stimuler des mouvements
ça peut aussi se retourner ? Bah oui,
parce que alors si on parle de
simulation de mouvement, quand il y a eu
quand les Américains ont décidé
euh vu la situation très complexe qu'il
y avait au Moyen-Orient à l'époque, il
faut s'en souvenir, euh avec les
tensions dans tous les sens et la
certitude pour beaucoup que les régimes
en place allaient sauter les uns après
les autres. Bon, quand les Américains
ont constaté ça et ont vu que on sont
dit le danger c'est que ce soit des gens
type Al-Qaïda qui prennent le pouvoir,
il faut qu'on empêche ça. Donc ils ont
choisi les frères musulmans.
Ils ont choisi les frères musulmans
parce que les frères musulmans à
l'époque paraissait être un
intermédiaire acceptable entre Al-Qaïda
et puis je dirais les les gens normaux
dans les pays. Islamisme mais pas trop.
Donc ils ont les les Américains on le
sait, on a des preuves, c'est
particulièrement flagrant en ce qui
concerne l'Égypte, mais dans tous les
autres pays aussi hein, ils ont ils ont
favorisé la prise du pouvoir, ils ont
créé les conditions pour que il y a une
prise du pouvoir par les frères
musulmans.
Ça s'est retourné
contre eux parce que on a vu justement
que les frères musulmans n'étant pas
capables de gérer les pays. On l'a vu le
président Morsi en particulier hein
comme ils étaient pas capable de gérer
le pays. On l'a vu aussi en en Tunisie
hein avec au début les les débuts des
NAD le comme les dirigeants flè
musulmans n'étaient pas capables de
gérer le pays, il y a eu un retournement
de la population et on a amené des gens
qui étaient exactement à l'opposé.
Si si c'est un c'est c'est pas un frère
musulman, c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire. C'est même un adversaire total
irréductible des frères musulmans. Bon,
on voit bien aujourd'hui en Tunisie que
le président qui a été choisi et
sélectionné hein au fur et à mesure
après tous les troubles qu'on a connu
n'est pas du tout profrin musulman. Donc
on voit bien que tout ce montage qui
avait été fait à l'époque hein y compris
d'ailleurs en Syrie, tout ce montage a
complètement échoué. Donc oui, ça
arrive.
Revenons à à l'Afghanistan.
[raclement de gorge]
On doit s'attendre à quoi ? On doit
s'attendre à
des talibans sous couverture de
mouvement islamistes où on doit
s'attendre à des Talibans qui sont
devenus des proxy américains contre les
mouvements radicaux encore plus radicaux
queeux. Est-ce qu'on doit s'attendre à
ce que les mouvements radicaux
identifient les talibans comme des
proaméricains et donc des cibles à
abattre ? Est-ce qu'on doit s'attendre à
des flux de migrants très importants ?
Ouai.
Alors, d'abord sur les talibans, il faut
pas oublier que quand
la guerre, les Américains ont fait la
guerre contre Ben Laden, hein, euh, ils
avaient demandé au taliban de lui livrer
Ben Laden. Et les talibans ont dit
jamais parce que c'est un c'est un
musulman. Donc,
montrez montrez-nous les preuves, ils
évitent.
Ouais, voilà. Exactement. Et donc, ils
ont ils ont refusé. Bon, il y a eu donc
il mais quand on regarde l'époque
euh les talibans effectivement c'est
tous c'était comme on disait des
étudiants islamiques he au départ formés
au Pakistan. faut pas l'oublier. Il y a
quand même l'influence pakistanaise. Bon
euh c'est un ces ces gens-là, ils
étaient ils voulaient imposer leur
système, un islam très dur, un islam
rigoriste,
salafiste. Mais
les talibans n'ont jamais été des
terroristes contre l'Occident ailleurs
qu'en Afghanistan.
On peut pas dire une fois qu'il y a eu
une attaque de taliban dans un autre
pays, hein, un attentat de il y en a pas
eu. Les talibans s'intéressent à leur
pays et je crois que c'est ça qui est
important. Alors, le problème actuel
c'est et ça on sait pas ce qui s'est
discuté entre les Américains et et les
Talibans à DOA, hein. DOA, entre
parenthèses soutien des frères musulmans
hein officiel ça bah ouais et qui va
maintenant gérer le problème de
l'aéroport de Kaboule parce qu'il fait
l'intermédiaire entre les deux côtés ce
qui montre bien les positions
respectives des uns et des autres. Bon,
les talibans, ils veulent eux, je crois
vraiment, ils veulent contrôler le pays
à leur manière.
Ils veulent le gérer à leur manière et
ils ont appris ils ont appris de ce qui
s'est passé parce que par exemple quand
ils avaient pris le pouvoir la première
fois
en bon en bon islamiste pur et dur hein,
ils ont dit on n' pas le droit de
produire de la drogue.
Donc ils avaient à l'époque interdit la
culture de la du pavo par les paysans
afghans.
Ça a été terrible pour les Afghans parce
que le paysan afghan, il il pouvait plus
manger, il avait plus rien parce que à
part la culture du pau, il y avait rien.
Donc les talibans se sont mis à dos une
très grande partie de la population et
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
ils ont été battus la première fois
hein.
Dès que les Américains, les Alliés, tout
le monde ont repris le contrôle de
l'Afghanistan avec leurs alliés locaux,
hein, la production de drogue est
repartie en flèche puisqueils sont
maintenant leaders mondiaux.
L'Afghanistan est leader mondial. Bon,
les Américains et les autres et les
alliés sont repartis maintenant. Mais
qu'est-ce qu'on dit les talibans ? Ils
ont dit "Nous n'allons pas réduire
la production de drogue parce qu'on a
bien compris que sinon on va se mettre à
dos une partie de la population, la
population rurale." Donc ça c'est un
premier point. Et puis ils ont compris
aussi que ça rapportait énormément
d'argent. Or cet argent qui est parti
dans les poches des dirigeants afghans
et des voyoux qui faisaient les
intermédiaires, aujourd'hui c'est clair
que les talibans vont le récupérer.
Alors ils vont le récupérer pourquoi ?
Bah certainement pour faire des
investissements locaux.
sur les flux de migrants.
[raclement de gorge] Si si le pays est
exposé par exemple
à des mouvements talibron très très
agressif, est-ce qu'ils vont commencer à
se mettre sur la route pour faire des
des des exodes ? Est-ce que ça va
déstabiliser les pays ?
Alors oui. Alors, il faut faire il faut
faire il y a un sondage qui est sorti
qui a été fait en Afghanistan hein
récemment
par qui ?
Euh j'arrive plus à savoir qui mais
c'est une des gens sérieux. Enfin, c'est
pas c'est pas une man enfin a priori
c'est pas une manipulation.
80, je crois que c'est 82 ou 83 %
des Afghans sont pour l'application de
la charia
très important parce que 89 80 % si on
prend dans tous les pays les il y a
entre 45 et 55 % de femmes et d'hommes
sur les pays. Bon, ça veut dire que la
majorité des femmes et des hommes de ce
pays sont pour l'application de la
chariur.
Oui. Oui. Mais oui, mais mais ça veut
donc dire que
le le problème des réfugiés concerne le
reste.
Dans le reste, il y a qui ? Il y a ceux
qui ont vraiment cru à l'Occident,
les pauvres qui ont vraiment cru que
l'Occident resterait toujours et leur
garantierit cette évolution qu'ils
souhaitait, hein. Le passage du 16e
siècle au 20e siècle ou 21e siècle.
Ceux-là, bien entendu, ils sont dans une
situation désespérée ceux-là parce que
ils vont pas se réhabituer, ils vont pas
retomber dans ce qu'ils essayaient de
fuir avec de avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasme.
Je pense on parle du aux femmes en
particulier qui se sont euh beaucoup
impliqués. Donc ça c'est clair que cela
ils vont partir. Et puis il y a ceux qui
ont été qui sont poursuivis par les
talibans pour d'autres raisons
également. C'est tous ceux qui ont eu un
rôle un peu trouble parce que dans les
dans l'histoire dans les dans toutes les
les provinces d'Afghanistan,
il y a des gens qui ont joué des jeux où
dans lequels la corruption le enfin il y
avait beaucoup de choses qui jouaient et
ceux-là évidemment sont aussi des
victimes. Alors ils essaient de partir.
Alors certains à mon avis la plupart
sont déjà partis mais alors ensuite
qu'est-ce qui va se passer ? Ces
réfugiés ils vont aller où ?
D'abord, ce sont des gens très pauvres
[grognement] hein. Et les filières, il y
en a pas tellement. Il on peut aller sur
l'Iran, mais il faut se rappeler quand
même que les les les Afghans ne sont pas
chites à part la la frange qui est sur
la frontière iranienne. Ce sont des
sunnites. Or, en Iran, les sunnites sont
pas très bien vus. C'est moins même si
les choses s'arrangent mais euh ils sont
pas très bien vus. Si on va de l'autre
côté, c'est les Chinois. Les Chinois,
ils ne souhaitent pas recevoir des gens
parce qu'ils ont déjà des problèmes avec
les igour chez eux. Ils ont passé des
accords au niveau des wigours avec les
talibans pour que les talibans n'aident
pas la le problème, hein. Donc ils ont
ils vont bloquer la frontière. Donc il
reste quoi ? Il reste les Républiques de
l'Asie centrale, le le Turkministan, bon
tous ces pays, ces quelques pays qui
sont là qui vont recevoir des gens en
grand nombre mais qui après ne pourront
pas les garder parce qu'ils n'ont pas la
capacité. Donc il va falloir trouver une
solution. Et je crois que la on en est
pas à la Turquie hein. On en est pas
arrivé à la Turquie, à la frontière de
un mot sur la Turquie, même plusieurs.
On en est où avec la Turquie ? C'est le
bassin le bassin de rétention de toutes
nos erreurs.
Oui. Et puis je pense qu'il y a Oui. La
Turquie c'est une c'est une série
d'erreurs majeures, hein. Ça commence
d'abord par la mise en place d'un frère
musulman ou d'un quasi frère musulman à
la tête du pays pour les raisons que
j'expliquais tout à l'heure. On voulait
que tout l'arc, la Turquie, la Syrie,
partout, on voulait que ce soit des
frères musulmans. On a vu le résultat
hein. Et le problème c'est que quand
les Turcs et les Américains se sont
rendus compte de ce que l'erreur qui
avait été faite avec Erdogan
dont je rappelle que la femme avait la
la tête nue jusque le jour de l'élection
présidentielle et qu'à partir du moment
où son mari a été élu, elle a mis elle a
mis le voile là, ce qui montre bien donc
c'était le la ce qu'on appelle la takya
en arabe, c'est-à-dire le mensonge.
Elle s'était elle s'est se cacher là.
Oui. Se cachait, c'est ça hein. Alors la
Turquie et bien sûr la Turquie a réussi.
Alors il faut malgré la tentative de
coup d'état de goule,
Erdogan a réussi jusqu'à maintenant en
tout cas à contrôler la situation en
Turquie
avec des problèmes avec l'armée, avec
des problèmes beaucoup d'ondes, mais il
il a contrôlé la situation. il est
seulement face à un problème économique,
c'est que ça marche pas si bien qu'avant
et que les gens ont des difficultés
financières et que ça, on sait pas le
résultat que ça pourra donner. Mais
c'est vrai qu'il a joué pour
contrebalancer ses difficultés internes,
il a su jouer sur le grand empire
ottoman avec la Syrie, avec la Libye,
avec les menaces sur la Grèce et sur la
zone pétrolière de Chypre. Donc il joue
sur tous les tableaux pour euh affirmer
sa place de grands leader au niveau de
la zone. Et il a l'appui des Américains
parce que c'est ça qu'il faut regarder
aussi.
C'est contrairement à ce qu'on nous
raconte, il a l'appui des Américains
parce que la la base d'Inque en en
Turquie est la deuxième plus grosse base
américaine dans tout le Moyen-Orient,
base nucléaire, hein. Et d'une part et
d'autre part parce que pour les Turcs
l'armée et ça c'est très important bon
pardon pour les Américains l'armée
turque est une armée essentielle dans le
cadre de l'OTAN parce que c'est c'est le
représentant le plus à l'est de l'OTAN
et bien sûr les Américains comptent
énormément sur lui. Du coup, il lui
pardonne beaucoup de choses et puis
comme en plus ils veulent se dégager de
tout le Moyen-Orient maintenant qui sont
autosuffisant grâce au gaz et au pétrole
de chiste aux États-Unis, hein. Donc,
ils n'ont plus besoin du Moyen-Orient,
ce qu'avait dit Trump et ce qu'on voit
maintenant et ce que confirme Biden.
Donc,
même encore des gros imports là.
Oui, mais il continue à acheter. Mais
c'est plus il pourrait tenir sans ça.
Il il pourrai tenir plus longtemps.
Exactement. Donc ils sont dans une
situation où ce n'est plus un besoin
stratégique vital. Voilà. Donc ils
disent "On veut sortir." Mais pour
sortir, il faut pas oublier qu'ils ont
un deux problèmes. Le premier c'est la
protection d'Israël. D'où les accords
d'Abrahams qu'a signé Trump qui qui
modifie complètement le Moyen-Orient. on
le voit bien actuellement hein et que
les Français n'ont pas compris ou on est
complètement passé à côté des accords
d'Avams alors qu'ils sont fondamental
fondamentaux pour l'avenir du
Moyen-Orient.
Pourquoi on est passé à côté ? parce
qu'on a des débiles, parce queon voulait
pas
parce qu'on a des a priori et je pense
que pas de nos services ont été des
défaillants.
Je crois il faut le dire comme le sait
hein. On n pas vu le coup venir et on n
pas su on n pas su s'y préparer.
Donc on s'est fait surprendre donc on a
perdu.
Voilà, on s'est fait surprendre, on a
perdu et du coup les Américains eux ils
s'appuient au nord sur les Turcs en
disant les Turcs. Voilà. Mais et avec
l'Arabie Saoudite, ils ont des rapports
beaucoup plus difficiles, ça c'est
clair. Euh
pourquoi ?
Parce qu'ils arrê
parce qu'ils n parce que parce qu'ils
n'ont plus les Américains n'ont, même si
les relations sont améliorées ces
derniers temps, les Américains sont
convaincus étaient convaincus que la la
l'Arabie Saoudite ne pourrait pas tenir
longtemps avec le système tel qu'il
était. Ils étaient convaincus qu'il y
aurait une révolution en Arabie
Saoudite. D'ailleurs, ça a été déjà la
raison de l'invasion de l'Irak. La
véritable raison de l'invasion de l'Irak
par les Américains, c'est pas de lutter
contre un dictateur. Parce qu'alors là,
il faut si on fallait tuer,
Ouais. fallait tuer tous les dans le
monde, on n pas fini là hein, on
s'épuiserait pour rien. Non, le problème
qu'ils avaient c'était si l'Arabie
Saoudite entrait en crise majeure avec
une révolution interne, leur problème
d'approvisionnement pétrolier à l'époque
était terrible. Donc ils sont dit "On
met la main sur l'Irak avec le pétrole
de Mossou, le Bassorail de toute cette
zone et c'est plus ces zones. On met la
main là-dessus et comme ça, on a un
porte-avion de secours et on se fout de
la l'Arabie Saoudite parce qu'on a le
porte-avion de secours. Bon, ça s'est
pas passé comme ça parce qu'ils ont
loupé l'Irak, moins qu'on puisse dire
l'Irak et la Syrie. Et puis et qu'en
Arabie, alors MBS avec des moyens qu'on
peut très cerman. Oui, excuse-moi. Oui,
excuse-moi. Mohamed Ben Salman qui est
le fils du roi mais un des fils du roi
mais qui tient le pays, qui gère le pays
et d'une main de fer, a senti le danger
et a fait évoluer le pays, est en train
de le faire évoluer là aussi à marche
forcée avec des méthodes dictatoriales,
hein. Mais il le fait évoluer de manière
à éviter justement ces troubles et que
la famille régnante et les familles
régnantes puissent continuer à gérer le
pays. Donc c'est lui les l'Arabie
Saoudite évolue très vite
indiscutablement
mais les Américains ont perdu ont perdu
confiance parce que eux ce qui les
intéresse c'est
Israël et ils ont réglé le problème avec
les Émirats avec tout le monde grâce aux
accords d'Abraham.
Au nord, il y a la Turquie et il reste
l'Iran avec lequel
les Américains actuellement sont coincé
parce qu'évidemment les Iraniens ne
veulent pas lâcher lâcher le morceau et
on les comprend un peu parce qu'il faut
quand même pas oublier qu'on leur a fait
signer un accord disant vous ne faites
pas la bombe atomique hein et on va vous
donner on va vous ouvrir les frontières
et vous allez retrouver une économie et
une fois qu'ils ont signé et qu'ils ont
dit "OK arrête la production pour la
bombe atomique. On leur a dit ben bonne
nouvelle, nous on vous laisse rien du
tout, on vous met en blocus. Bon et même
pire, on a encore aggravé le blocus.
Donc on a les les occidentaux n'ont
absolument pas tenu leurs engagements.
C'est Trump qui avait fait ça. Mais
l'Europe a été incapable de d'empêcher
Trump de le faire ou de contourner les
décisions de Trump. Alors, on comprend
que les Iraniens se méfient et disent
"Avant qu'on signe un accord avec les
Américains, il faudra du temps." Mais ce
que les gens ne voient pas euh
[grognement] en France et ailleurs,
c'est que actuellement, il y a des
négociations, on le sait, entre les
Iraniens et les Saoudiens.
Donc, les chefs sunnites et les chefs
chiites, ils sont en train de négocier.
Or, s'ils arrivent à un accord entre
eux,
et ben à ce moment-là, c'est fini. On a
plus de problème au Moyen-Orient. Et
moi, j'ai personnellement je pense que
c'est ça auquel on va arriver. C'estàd
qu'on va se faire courtcircuiter
les Européens, les Américain parce qu'on
a pas su tenir nos engagements
sérieusement à l'époque où on les avait
pris et qu'en contrepartie par contre
les Saoudiens, les Émiratis et les
Israéliens trouveront une solution.
Alors Israël avec Benamin Etou, c'était
impossible parce que toute sa politique
avait été faite. Il n'existait que par
opposition à l'Iran. Bon donc lui
évidemment c'est pas lui qui allait
négocier mais Benet est la nouvelle
équipe la nouvelle équipe israélienne
elle a la capacité de négocier un accord
à partir du moment où cet accord
assurait la sécurité d'Israël. C'est
clair. Et moi je pense que alors ça ça
va pas se faire en un jour hein, mais je
pense qu'on va vers ça. Je pense qu'on
va un on va vers un accord interne entre
tous ces pays.
Ce qui en à ce moment-là dit rendrait
plus difficile la position de la Turquie
pour terminer sur la question posée hein
puisque la si jamais l'Iran, l'Arabie
Saoudite et les autres signent un accord
général, la Turquie sera beaucoup moins
forte dans ce qu'elle voudrait être à
savoir le contrôle du Moyen-Orient. En
définitive, c'est l'Empire ottoman.
L'Empire Perse, c'est l'Empire égyptien.
Évidemment, c'est un peu compliqué.
Vous avez répondu à moitié à la question
que je voulais vous poser, mais je vais
vous la poser quand même. À chaque fois
qu'on utilise l'expression
la guerre contre le terrorisme, la
guerre contre la drogue, la guerre
contre le Covid, à chaque fois, c'est un
échec cuisant. H
comme qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ? Il
faut virer les gars qui sont en charge
de faire les stratégies. Il faut virer
les gars qui sont en charge de mettre
sur le terrain en pratique la stratégie.
Il faut changer notre appréciation, il
faut changer d'expression, faut changer
nos méthodes. Pourquoi on échoue ? Et et
et la fin de ma question, c'est
là, on a pris 20 ans de guerre en
Afghanistan.
Ouais.
Est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a des
têtes au Pentagone qui vont sauter ?
C'est-à-dire, il y a eu des milliers de
milliards qui ont été investis
pour un résultat qui est
nul.
Nul. Qu'est-ce qui se passe dans le
privé s'il y a des investissements qui
amènent à nul ? Tout le monde se fait
virer.
Donc enfin, pas en France,
mais effectivement dans le monde
capitaliste en général, si vous échouez
dans une dans une société, vous partez.
Bon.
Euh le problème, je crois que c'est il y
a plusieurs problèmes dans la dans cette
question.
Le premier c'est que les militaires font
ce qu'on leur demande de faire.
Si vous demandez à un militaire de jouer
hein dans un sens alors qu'il n'a pas
les moyens de le faire jusqu'au bout,
vous ne pouvez pas y arriver.
Vous savez, moi je me souviens d'une
phrase que j'ai entendu par des des
responsables au Mali, des milice au Mali
qui se battent contre Bokoaram et
Al-Qaïda enfin à l'époque avec donc il
se bat contre les islamistes et ce galin
me disait Alain il faudrait ici nous
faudrait les Russes
alors je pourquoi il faudrait les Russes
l'armée française oui mais les Russes ne
s'embarrassent pas des droits de
l'homme.
Et et c'est un peu indéfinitif, c'est un
peu ça. On peut pas faire la guerre en
dentelle.
Or, nous les pays occidentaux,
on peut pas on peut pas faire la guerre
autrement qu'en dentelle parce que les
des associations bien pensantes, le
politique qui change d'avis en fonction
des sondages, il y a tout un ensemble.
La population qui est sensibilisée par
les médias dans un sens ou dans un
autre. Tout ça fait que on ne peut pas
faire vraiment la guerre. Je te coupe,
je vais me faire l'avocat du diable.
Oui.
Est-ce qu'on doit être plus bourreau que
les bourreaux ?
C'est-à-dire
Oui, j'ai compris. Oui, ben je je pense
pas je pense pas qu'il faut être plus
bourreaux que les bourreaux, mais je
pense que dans ce genre de guerre où la
il faut que l'un clairement soit perçu
par l'autre comme le dominateur
pour évacuer les chances de victoire. Il
faut dans dans une guerre le moment clé
c'est au moment où il y en a un des bell
gérants comprend que il a perdu.
et qui s'en sortira pas.
Ce qu'il y a, c'est que nous
les pays occidentaux,
on ne sait on ne sait pas taper très
fort au départ
ou alors on le fait dans des conditions
qui nous mettent les populations locales
à dos, hein. En garde Afghanistan, on a
eu le nombre de morts civiles comme en
Irak, le nombre de morts maintenant
estimé par toutes les associations
spécialisées et c'est considérable. On
est on est au million de personnes
civiles.
Donc est-ce que à partir alors qu'est-ce
qui se passe quand quand on a mettons
10000 ou 20000 ou même 100 allez 50000
combattants contre soi et que on en tue
quelques-uns mais qu'il y a 1 million
d'individus
hein qui sont tués des civils et ben on
se fout de toute la population civile à
dos et
on s'en fait 300000 de plus.
Exactement. Et cette population civile
bien sûr qu'elle comme elle aura basculé
avec les autres bah ça ne va pas ranger
nos affaires. Donc je crois que c'est ça
le problème. Je crois que moi je crois
vraiment que on ne sait plus faire la
guerre aujourd'hui.
Les pays occidentaux hein, on ne sait
plus faire la guerre parce que nous
sommes-nous dans une guerre en dentelle
sans brutalité mais tout en faisant des
morts en Syrie, hein. et face à et de
l'autre côté, ce sont des gens qui eux
font la guerre sans pitié, je dirais, on
le voit bien, hein. Alors, bien sûr, il
y a entre les deux, ben
il y a un problème. Alors, bien alors
les beaucoup d'ONG disent oui, mais
justement nous des peuples développés,
démocrates et autres, il faut il faut il
faut justement garder nos valeurs.
Garder nos valeurs, oui, mais ne pas
être dup et ne pas se laisser faire
parce qu'en gardant nos valeurs, hein,
si on se laisse faire, on perd tout.
On on n pas on n pas réussi. La preuve,
c'est qu'on a en Afghanistan, on a
investi, je crois que c'est 8000
milliards pendant ce je pense ces 20 ans
sur l'Afghanistan.
Bon, le système s'est effondré en
quelques jours. Ça prouve on n pas
réussi à fidéliser les gens. On n pas
réussi à les positionner comme il
fallait. Bon et bien et ça c'est le
problème
avec votre expérience
je vais pas dire que vous êtes au
crépuscule de votre vie.
Ah oui si si quand même quand même. J'en
ai fait au moins la plus grande partie,
ça c'est sûr.
Vous avez quelle prospective pour la
France
à 5 et 10 ans ? Hm.
On va euh dans un bourbier, on va dans
la débacle, on va dans un effondrement
ou au contraire on va dans une dans un
chemin beaucoup plus joyeux, beaucoup
plus rose où tout le monde va s'aimer.
Bah alors, c'est c'est compliqué mais je
vais reprendre je vais repartir de
l'exemple militaire parce que je pense
c'est un bon exemple pour expliquer ma
pensée sur ce qui se passe.
Quand on regarde le problème des pays du
Sahel, du Mali et les autres,
première opération française, quand on a
vu les attentats qui commençaient dans
le coin, on a envoyé nos militaires, les
troupes, les forces spéciales et de
troupes d'intervention en disant il faut
éliminer les cibats terroristes, les
compagnies terroristes partout où elles
sont.
On a fait ça en 2 ans magistralement, ça
on sait faire.
Mais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé après ?
Il s'est passé la même chose que pour
les Américains en Irak qui avaient fait
une formidable campagne pour gagner la
guerre, hein. C'était l'achat de la
cavalerie légère à l'époque, hein. Bon,
très bien. Et après, qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé ? Dans tous les cas, c'est la même
chose. C'est quand une armée
de conquête qui elle va très vite,
qui élimine
les mauvais éléments, se transforme en
armée d'occupation. L'armée
d'occupation, elle est piégée entre la
routine, le manque de moyens, les
pressions publiques, les changements
politiques. Bref, elle est tiraillée
dans tous les sens et quelle que soit la
qualité des hommes qui y sont, et ben
ils peuvent pas y arriver. On peut pas
les attaquer. C'est pour ça qu'on peut
pas tirer sur les Américains en
Afghanistan en disant les généraux ont
été nuls. Non, les généraux, ils ont
fait ce qu'ils pouvaient faire avec les
moyens qu'ils avaient et compte tenu de
ce qu'on leur a donné comme instruction.
Parce que je suis certain que si à
l'époque de Petraus en particulier
Cristal
Oui, McCrystal aussi les deux, ils ont
été tous les deux remarquables ces deux
grands généraux américains, c'est s'ils
avaient eu les pou le pouvoir de faire
réellement ce que eux voulaient, on nen
serait pas là aujourd'hui. Quel problème
? Quand vous regardez
dans le gouvernement taliban
d'aujourd'hui, il y a quatre
[grognement] ministres qui sortent de
Guantanamo.
Ça pose quand même question.
Ils ont été réduqués.
Oui, ils ont été rééduqués. On les a
enfermé, on les a torturé parce qu'il
faut pas l'oublier quand même hein. On
les a torturé comme jamais. Enfin, comme
jamais. Oui, je pense qu'on a ils ont
pulvérisé les records de torture à
l'époque hein.
Nous en garde d'Algérie, on était pas
mal quand même.
Ah non non quand même jamais. Quand on
pense que Rallet Cheik Mohamed le chef
des opérations de l'Alqaïda, 110
passages à la baignoire,
il faut se souvenir de Barbie à à Lyon
qui faisait passer les gens. C
épouvantable torture. Il faisait passer
les résistants. Ceux qui l'ont raconté
c'était deux trois fois quatre fois. Là,
les Américains l'ont fait passer 110
fois. Ils l'ont détruit, ça c'est clair,
hein. Il est toujours vivant, mais dans
quel état, hein ? Mais donc, ils ont ils
ont donc ils ont appliqué un certain
nombre de choses. Et le résultat c'est
quoi ? Et ben, il y en a quatre de
Guantanamo qui sont sortis, rééduqués
et qui sont maintenant bon, est-ce qu'on
peut attendre de ces gens-là qu'ils
aiment l'Occident sérieusement
après ce qu'ils ont subi ? Faut quand
même, faut arrêter. hein,
il n'empêche que ils peuvent être
touchés par la grâce en prison
parce que il faut se souvenir de
Mandela. C'est l'affaire Mandela. Mandé
indiscutablement en prison, a eu le
temps de réfléchir, a changé et Mandela
est sorti en étant un révolutionnaire
certes, mais un révolutionnaire qui
était prêt à faire la paix, qui était
qui avait une autre vision. Le drame de
l'Afrique du Sud, c'est que après lui ça
ça a mal tourné. Mais avec lui, la
l'Afrique du Sud était bien partie,
hein. Bon et ben ce problème-là, on le
retrouve un peu partout en définitive.
Revenons revenons à la France. Nos
capacités à survivre à cette
mondialisation,
à ce réchauffement climatique, à ces
mouvements de population,
franchement
B, il faut qu'on affronte la réalité en
face.
Il faut se retrousser les manches.
Oui. Bah bien sûr, mais il faut qu'on
Oui, il faut qu'on affronte la réalité
en face. D'abord, il faut se poser la
question, je crois. Il faut se poser la
question de savoir si nous sommes une
République ou une démocratie. C'est pas
moi qui l'ai dit, c'est c'est Régis
Debré qui a fait un livre très
intéressant il y a une dizaine d'années
là-dessus en expliquant que la
République elle alors que les
démocraties à l'anglo-saxone
communautarisent.
Dans la communautarisation, on coordonne
les communautés.
Dans la République, on demande que
chacun assimile les valeurs de la
République. C'est pas du tout la même
chose. Et là, c'est un vrai choix. La
France est face à un vrai choix. Est-ce
qu'on bascule dans la démocratie à
l'anglo-saxone ? Mais attention, il faut
qu'on change tout parce que c'est des
groupes communautaristes qui vivent les
uns à côté des autres.
Ou alors est-ce qu'on continue à
défendre les valeurs de la République ?
Alors, il faut aller jusqu'au bout dans
la défense des valeurs de la République.
C'est parce que l'intégration, ça
suppose une formation, ça suppose de
l'éducation, ça suppose beaucoup de
choses, hein.
On est plus capable de faire ça.
Bah, justement la question c'est mais
est-ce qu'on est capable de faire
l'autre aussi ? C'est ça la question.
Aujourd'hui, on peut se poser la
question de savoir si nous sommes
capables sérieusement de prendre un des
choix et d'essayer de faire quelque
chose. Si si
aujourd'hui, ça flotte de partout, il
faut dire la vérité. On flotte de
partout.
Ouais. Si si permettez-moi l'expression,
on est le cul entre deux chaises.
Oui.
On si on tombe si on prend pas un
chemin,
qu'est-ce qui va se passer pour la
France ? Une lente décomposition.
[soupir] On va
Oui, mais c'est c'est l'histoire mais
c'est l'histoire des de tous les grands
les peuples qui ont il faut reprendre
l'histoire. Alors, je sais que le
président veut déconstruire l'histoire,
mais peut-être parce que justement elle
lui fait peur.
Parce que quand on regarde l'histoire
d'ancienne, on voit comment les
royaumes, comment les empires ont
disparu et ils ont disparu dans des
processus qui ressemblent étrangement à
ceux que nous vivons actuellement. Et je
parle pas uniquement de la France, je
parle de nos pays, du sud de l'Europe,
je parle et je parle de de l'Angleterre.
Je même l'Allemagne qui a qui a fait une
formidable percée pendant le Covid hein
parce que l'Allemagne a pris une avance
sur tout le monde. Avant il y avait
avant le Covid il y avait un couple
franco-allemand. Maintenant, il y a
l'Allemagne et puis il y a le reste de
l'Europe. He c'est clair hein. Il faut
être les politiques bien sûr disent pas
ça, mais la réalité elle est là. Je vais
regarder les chiffres hein. Comme le
disait je sais plus qui l'autre jour, le
les Allemands on remboursé la dette
covid en 2000 en 2028 et nous en 2068.
La guer la macédite hein, c'est clair.
Bon mais malheureusement parce que je
m'en réjouis pas hein. C'est clair que
je m'en réjouis pas mais on est dans un
système dans lequel
on peut plus se relier au on n pas on a
on a c'est le problème de tous ces
empires ou ces royaumes qui
disparaissent.
ou ces états qui disparaissent, c'est
qu'à partir du moment où tout flotte, il
n'y a plus la capacité de mobilisation
suffisante pour repartir de l'avant.
Alors ben je sais que la en France bon
prent Macron lui il voit il voit
l'Europe comme solution de sortie
mais mais je pense que l'Europe ne
marchera pas non plus telle qu'il a
qu'il la voit non plus parce que
l'Europe est totalement différente.
L'Europe aujourd'hui elle est coupée
entre l'Europe du Nord le groupe de
visade qui a des visées qui n'ont
absolument rien à voir avec celle du
nord du sud hein. On a les pays du sud
qui ont aussi qui ont aussi leur
problème et qui sont regardez l'Italie,
regardez l'Espagne hein et puis et puis
et puis nous hein. Au milieu il y a
l'Allemagne, mais l'Allemagne selon ce
qui va se passer dans quelques jours,
elles sont l'élection. Si c'est ce que
je ne crois pas, si c'est le CDU qui de
qui passe en tête, bon, ils continueront
à peu près la politique actuelle. Mais
si c'est comme tous les tous les
sondages l'indiquent le SPD, euh là il
va y avoir des changements de stratégie
importants et qui vont poser problèmes à
nous mais qui vont aussi poser des
problèmes aux Américains et aux autres
d'ailleurs
quel regard vous avez sur la guerre
contre le Covid en terme de logistique
d'organisation de faire passer ça à la
population.
Est-ce que ça a bien été fait ? C'est ça
a été pas très bien fait. Je crois que
c'est le résultat la anti antivax en
plus tout ça. Bon, je pense que c'est le
résultat des flottements de l'État
pendant la première année du Covid parce
que
même les premiers jours du covid
Oui, même les premiers jours. Vous savez
moi
après
euh quand on regarde les premiers les le
début du Covid hein, l'État savait pas
où il était.
Ils ont alors on disait il faut pas
mettre de masques. Maintenant regardez,
on doit tous mettre des masques. On
disait que les masques ça servait à
rien. Enfin, on nous a raconté plein
d'histoires. En réalité l'État flottait.
Cherchait des solutions, on n'en avait
pas.
Mais c'est quoi l'État ? L'État c'est
nous.
Ah oui, mais attendez, l'administration
de l'État et les politiques de l'État
étaient anéantis devant face à un
problème qu'il ne maîtrisait pas.
Mais pourquoi ils étaient anéantis ?
parce que on avait oublié euh parce que
pourtant il y a eu des expériences. Le
si on regarde l'histoire une fois de
plus en 1910 de 1917 à 1920 la grippe
qu'on a appelé la grippe espagnole on
voit maintenant tous les médecins vous
le diront maintenant que c'était un
Covid c'est clair et net. C'est la même
chose, c'est les mêmes symptômes et
tout. Donc ça donne il suffit de lire et
d'étudier tout ce qui s'est passé à
cette époque-là pour comprendre une
partie des choses qu'il faut faire.
Mais comme les c'est la plupart de nos
dirigeants ne lisent plus l'histoire
parce qu'il faut la déconstruire,
évidemment on prend pas de référence sur
le passé.
On croit que nous avec le progrès, on
est devenu géniaux. Ce n'est pas vrai.
On n'est pas plus géniaux qu'avant.
Le mode de vie est un peu différent mais
on n'est pas plus géniaux qu'avant.
Pour aller plus loin
dans la dans la dans cette affaire dans
cette affaire, il faut se souvenir quand
on allait on parlait de la guerre tout à
l'heure des guerres he quand on faisait
la guerre d'Algérie ou les autres
guerres et même aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
quand les militaires vont faire la
guerre en Afrique hein avant de partir
on les vaccine contre une série de
contre une série de maladies. Bon
comment ça se passe ? Bon, on leur dit
demain matin à l'infirmerie, ils sont
tous en rang d'union, on pique toute la
section ou la compagnie et puis on leur
dit pendant 48 heur vous sortez pas
parce que vous allez être un peu secoué
puis après c'est fini. On leur demande
pas l'autorisation de les vacciner.
Mais c'est des militaires.
Mais oui, mais attendez, mais pendant
des années, est-ce qu'on a posé des
questions quand on faisait les vaccins
pour les enfants et tout contre la
polio, la diférie, le tétanos ? Est-ce
qu'on a demandé aux gens leur avis ?
Bien sûr que non. Les seuls qui
refusaient, c'étaient les témoins de
Jéhovah. Bon et on l'admettait très
bien, c'était un cas de conscience et
donc on l'admettait. Mais en dehors des
témoins de Jéhova, tout le monde était
vacciné. Là comme on a hésité, ouais le
vaccin le vaccin enfin bref tout ce qui
a pu être raconté.
Ça a fait émerger toute une série de
gens qui ont dit mais moi je veux pas
être vacciné. Et pire encore
effectivement l'utilisation de vaccins
ARN donc des vaccins à système messager
comme on dit sur le cytoplasme. Bon ces
vaccins en définitive c'est vrai il faut
être honnête on ne connaît pas à long
terme le risque de ces vaccins. A priori
il y en a pas mais comme personne ne l'a
expérimenté on ne sait pas. Donc on peut
se on peut comprendre aussi que certains
puissent avoir des peurs raisonnés ou y
raisonner.
Maintenant le problème c'est qu'on n pas
voulu traiter tout ça. On n pas voulu
traiter les choses. On a on a imposé
l'État a imposé avec des coups de barre
à droite et à gauche a imposé un système
qui a de plus en plus exaspéré les gens.
Et pour arriver à la fin où il y a eu
effectivement un foyer de gens qui
disent "Moi, il n'est pas question qu'on
me vaccine pour de multiples raisons."
Bien sûr, politiquement parlant, ça a
été récupéré. Ben ça c'est classique
comme chaque fois comme les comme on
avait connu avec les gilets jaunes hein.
Le gilet jaune au départ, on sait très
bien pourquoi c'était. Bon bah c'était
la France un peu plus riche que le
c'était pas les pauvres, c'était ce
qu'on appelle la bourgeoise la base
bourgeoisie. C'estàd bourgeois. C'était
surtout les pauvres qui travaillaient.
Mais oui, mais qui gagnaient une vie
convenable. Mais tout juste.
Juste juste
tout juste tout juste. Et qui voyait que
leur niveau de vie dégringolait. Et là,
il disait c'est pas normal, je travaille
dur et mon mon niveau de vie baisse,
c'est pas acceptable. Et ils avaient
raison hein. Le problème c'est que là
aussi on a vu des récupérations par des
gens venant de partout. Donc à chaque
fois, c'est la même chose. Maintenant,
de même que pour les gilets jaunes, on
peut quand même se poser la question de
savoir si de passer de 90 à 80 euh les
routes départementales dans une vision
parisienne du problème. Est-ce que
c'était une bonne solution hein qui
alors que ça a provoqué la levée de
bouclier de la France profonde et des
campagnes ? l'augmentation de prix de ta
sur
voà ben il s'est passé la même chose. Si
on avait avec ce flou général hein sur
euh sur le départ le démarrage du Covid,
je crois qu'on en serait pas là
aujourd'hui.
Emmanuel Macron, chef d'étatmajor des
armées, vous avez confiance en lui ou
pas ?
Je p je pense que non le je pense que le
président de la République
statutairement et constitutionnellement
est le chef des armées.
Mais le chef des armées, ça veut dire
quoi ? Ça veut dire que c'est lui qui
prend la décision finale par rapport à
des propositions qui lui ont été faites
par les spécialistes.
Donc on mélange t si vous voulez la
guerre la quand on dit le regardez le
comité on le comité de défense se réunit
pour parler du Covid. Mais le Covid
c'est pas une guerre,
c'est la lutte contre une épidémie.
Pourquoi il y a un secret défense ?
Mais parce que ça protège les ministres
contre les poursuites judiciaires.
C'est tout.
Tout le monde a été marqué par l'affaire
du sang contaminé quand Laurent Fabius
et Georgina Dufois ont été attaqués par
la justice parce qu'elles avaient pris
ils avaient pris des décisions erronées
semble-t-il hein ? semble-t que je suis
très prudent hein sur le le sang
contaminé. Du coup, tous les politiques
ont retenu la leçon et disent il faut
surtout pas qu'on puisse nous prendre.
Comment on fait ? Et ben, on fait des
réunions dans lesquelles les décisions
sont collectives, générales et on ne
peut pas on ne peut pas savoir qui les a
prises. À ce moment-là, on est tous
protégés.
Magnifique.
C'est magnifique.
Oui. Et ça montre bien aussi les
limites. Les limites du chac pour
revenir à ce que vous disiez. Le chef
le chef il est là pour écouter ses
collaborateurs, prendre les meilleurs
d'entre eux et faire des choix entre les
solutions les meilleures proposées par
les meilleurs d'entre eux. Hein ? Le
chef d'étatmajor, lui, son boulot, c'est
connaissant parfaitement son domaine,
c'est de préparer justement les
différentes options que le chef va
prendre. Mais il faut pas substituer, il
faut pas supprimer les options
hiérarchiques.
Un chef doit savoir cheffer, c'est ça ?
Ben un chef, il doit surtout savoir que
il ne sait pas tout et que la guerre,
c'est une chose compliquée, très
compliquée même. La preuve, on les perd
toutes, hein. Et donc plutôt que de
vouloir diriger, prendre les décisions,
il faut essayer de s'entourer de gens
qui peuvent utilement vous conseiller.
C'est comme dans les entreprises, c'est
pareil.
Les grands patrons d'entreprise, les
vrais grands patrons d'entreprise, quand
vous les regardez, ce sont des gens qui
ont des experts autour d'eux qui ont
généralement une un premier niveau et un
deuxième niveau tout à fait remarquable.
Trois noms de grands chefs d'entreprise
pour vous ? Oh,
il y en a plein de grands chefs
d'entreprise.
Alors, juste trois.
Ah ben il y en a un il y en a un où
c'est un uni démonstration incroyable.
C'eston Musk
parce que je crois que c'est un type qui
a des idées mais lui il a les idées mais
après il faut les mettre en œuvre. Donc
il a su il a su derrière lui mettre
toute une série de gens qui sont
capables de mettre en œuvre de mettre en
musique les ses intuitions. C'est c'est
très fort hein.
De deux autres. Un français au minimum.
Ouais un français. Je vais quand même
m'en sortir des français. Ah ben moi
j'en ai plusieurs hein. J'en ai euh des
fois
Mustache. Moustache tu un gros patron
non
hein ?
Moustache
oui
je pense Margerie était un très grand
patron d'entreprise. Je pense qu'il
avait il avait à la fois la capacité de
négocier, le courage d'aller négocier.
C'est pas évident hein, mais en même
temps, c'était un type qui connaissait
parfaitement tous les rouages et qui
tenait compte. Et il avait il avait
aussi une équipe brillantissime autour
de lui dont d'ailleurs les Pouyané qui
est aujourd'hui devenu le président.
C'est c'était un grand patron. Margerie
était un grand patron
et puis en plus il était sympa.
Ouais mais vous savez il y en a d'autres
qui sont très moi je vois euh j'ai la
chance oui je peux dire j'ai la chance.
Moi, je suis dans je suis administrateur
d'un groupe qui s'appelle Altrade. Je
veux pas faire de la publicité pour un
groupe, mais Altrad, ce qui é
intéressant dans la dans la le groupe
Altrad, c'est que c'est un groupe
français. On fait 3 milliards et demi
aujourd'hui, mais ça va encore monter
bientôt, hein. On va en parler bientôt,
vous allez voir. Euh, encore monter. Il
est parti, au départ, c'est un Syrien
qui était dans une tribu dont la mère a
eu un enfant du chef de la tribu. Comme
il était doué, il a été envoyé par à
l'époque le père de Bachard en France
pour devenir pilote de chasse pour
l'armée syrienne. Et puis comme les
examens il marchaient bien, il était
très doué, ben il est resté et puis
après il a fait ses études en France et
ensuite il a monté, il a arraché une
petite société, il en a fait l'empire
actuel. Bon, pourquoi je le cite ? C'est
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui est d'une
grande modestie.
Grande modestie.
Mais lui il conçoit
et sa force, moi je l'ai regardé de très
près, ça m'a intéressé de voir comment
ça marchait hein. Sa force c'est qu' il
s'entoure de gens parfaitement adaptés
aux missions qu'il va confier
et ça marche au niveau mondial. Il s'est
motivé les gens pas seulement en France
mais ailleurs également. Et ça c'est et
ben c'est ça il faut le le chef c'est
quelqu'un qui a qui a la vision qui
donne l'objectif.
Ça c'est clair. Il a un objectif à moyen
ou long terme hein. Et à partir de là
derrière les autres vont voir comment on
peut y arriver et vont faire lui faire
des propositions pour voir comment y
arriver et lui dans les propositions va
faire le choix de celle qui lui paraît
la meilleure. Vous savez c'est de gaul
Pompidou hein. On est en train de on a
vécu pendant des années 60 aux années
presque 2000 sur la base de ce qu'ils
avaient imaginé he les avions,
l'aérospatial,
le nucléaire,
le nucléaire, on a eu on a eu plein de
choses hein qui ont été bon les on on a
dans plein de domaines, les trains, le
TGV, enfin dans plein de domaines, il y
avait eu des il avait des idées de des
grandes idées en disant il faut qu'on
fasse ça. Après, c'est pas lui qui
allait faire le nucléaire, le père de
Wall, c'est pas c'est pas Pompidou qui
allait faire le spatial. N'empêche que
ça a tenu pendant 30 ans. Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'ils avaient donné les idées,
ils ont choisi des gens qui étaient
capables de l'amener à bien et ils
avaient l'énergie et la force de faire
avancer les choses.
C'était Bernard Ezambert et Jacques
Blamon.
Exactement. Mais a été pour moi, il est
encore vivant. Ezambert a été un homme
extraordinaire parce que il fait partie
de ce petit nom méconnu hein par les
Français en général. Plus il est super
sympa.
Ah bon ? En plus, je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec hein et mais c'est des
gens méconnus mais qui ont qui ont
apporté à la qui ont permis à la France
de vivre 30 années exceptionnelles. Pas
mal hein,
c'est superbe.
Revenons à la guerre contre la drogue.
Oui.
Alors, la guerre contre la drogue, ça a
pas l'air de fonctionner mondialement
parlant, mais on continue on continue
gmentant à à faire cette guerre contre
la drogue. Comment on fait pour gagner
une guerre contre la drogue ?
B la guerre contre la drogue, il faut il
faut employer les moyens nécessaires. Je
reviens à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure, hein. La guerre, elle n'est
jamais propre.
C'est triste à dire, hein, parce que
c'est plus sympa de faire la guerre en
dentelle.
Il y a plus de de guerre chirurgicale,
c'est ça ?
Non, mais oui. Ouais, mais là, il faut
la guerre, c'est quand il faut il faut
il faut employer les moyens nécessaires
pour lutter. Bon, c'est sûr que
lorsqu'on voit le développement de la
drogue partout, hein,
ça fait des ravages terrible,
ça fait gagner de l'argent des fortunes
à un certain nombre de gens et onétudie
pas beaucoup les circuits de la drogue
parce que on regarde ceux qui sont les
plus riches, je dirais les trafiquants,
les grands trafiquants de drogue. Mais
on parle pas de tous ceux qui
bénéficient des retombées de la drogue
et qui se font arroser.
Et ça, il y en a partout, y compris dans
le politique,
hein. Moi, je vois au Mali, par exemple,
pour prendre des exemples africains, au
Mali, personne n'en parlait. Le Mali est
devenu un narcoétat.
Personne n'en parle en France. Le
président qui était avant, qui avant le
remplacement par les militaires
laissait faire un narcoétat. Bon et les
gens qui sont les trafiquants qui
gagnent énormément d'argent là-bas au
Mali et bien les des amis qui sont à
côté au Niger me disaient que ça y est
trafiquants commencent à financer les
élus de la République du Niger le
Parlement en particulier on commence à
voir des élateurs des trafiquants de
drogue parce que quand ces gens-là sont
très riches, ils achètent.
Donc il faut être extrêmement dur si
vous voulez. Moi je suis pas un amoureux
fou de la de la dureté du système
chinois, mais en Chine, quelqu'un qui
touche à la drogue, il y
que soit son niveau. Et ben, je vous
garantis que ça calme.
Alors, bien sûr, on va vous dire "Mais
comment il faut la vie humaine et tout
Oui, mais il y a des moments, je moi
personnellement avec l'âge que j'ai
maintenant, je pense qu'il y a des
moments où il faut pas c'est pas pas
être systématique mais il faut faire des
exemples. Il faut que les gens se
rendent compte que on ne rigole plus.
Alors là, ils font attention.
Faut faire des exemples aussi avec les
politiques. Par exemple, Agè Buisin qui
est convoqué par la Cour de justice.
Mais moi mais moi je moi j'attends. Je
ne dis pas qu'elle est coupable. J'en
sais, je connais pas le dossier hein, je
sais pas qu'elle est coupable.
Mais ce que je crois par contre, c'est
que quand quelqu'un est coupable,
il doit être condamné mais il doit être
condamné réellement.
Comprenez quand vous voyez des gens qui
se font condamnés 3 ans de prison, 5 ans
de prison et puis ils sont dehors ils
perorent, ils travaillent, on les voit.
Bon franchement mais pourquoi se priver
hein ? Il y a un moment il faut que ça
il faut il faut il faut que les États
aient le courage de dire stop.
Et je constate que dans le monde, mais
pas uniquement dans les systèmes type
Chine, mais dans nos pays, il commence à
avoir dans certains pays des réactions
du politique appuyé bien sûr par la
population qui disent il faut taper le
point sur la table en disant ça suffit
et il faut pas fermer les yeux sur un
certain nombre de dérives. Quand je vous
disais tout à l'heure, quand vous pensez
qu'on a fait la guerre en Yougoslavie,
les Balkans, la guerre des Balcans avec
tout ce qu'on a entendu et tout ce qu'on
a fait avec Sou des Bou Sarayevau, tout
ça, bon eux les Français sont impliqués
et ont fait de fort belles choses, fort
bell guerre, une fort belle guerre. Bon,
quand vous pensez que le résultat entre
autres, c'est une Bosnie qui est un état
mafieux à 100 % malgré tous les gens qui
l'ont dirigé, qui s'en sont impliqués de
la communauté internationale, hein, tu
rappelles que le premier responsable de
la Bosnie au niveau international
délégué, c'était monsieur Kouchner.
Bon et bien c'est aujourd'hui c'est
devenu un état mafieux. Or, ce sont les
mêmes hommes qui étaient à l'époque et
maintenant. Bon, c'est pas acceptable.
Vous me ferez pas croire qu'à l'époque,
on ne savait pas ce qui se passait, mais
on a fermé les yeux parce que à
l'époque, il y avait une volonté de
faire exploser la Yougoslavie et que
c'était ça qui était le seul le seul
objectif. Et dans ces cas-là, on dit
"Bon ben, on verra bien après, peu
importe." Et ben non, il faut penser aux
conséquences de ces actes.
C'est c'est ces gens-là, il
est-ce qu'il ils sont conscients
que ça fonctionne pas, qu'il continuent
à utiliser les mêmes méthodes, que que à
chaque fois le chien se retourne contre
la main qui la nourrit.
Oui.
Mais il continue. Alors ça vient de quoi
? Ça vient des écoles ? Ça vient de la
formation ? Mais je Oui, mais je Oui,
parce que mais je pense que nous sommes
dans un environnement
euh général, hein, un environnement qui
euh est défétiste par nature, dire qu'il
ne veut pas affronter les problèmes de
face, hein. Alors, c'est valable à tous
les dans tous les stades, hein.
Regard, regardez, regardez les écoles,
regardez l'école française. On est
avant-dernier en mathématiques au niveau
de l'Europe he d'après les classements
internationaux.
Comment le pays qui a été considéré il y
a encore 30 20 30 ans comme un des deux
pays avec les Russes à l'époque, un des
deux pays qui formaaient le mieux des
mathématiciens
des codeurs
et des codeurs, comment on arrive
maintenant à être 28 27e sur 28 ou 26e
sur 27 ? C'est c'est lamentable. Bon,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? parce que c'est
ça. Bon, on le constate et pas nous
d'ailleurs, les autres le constatent. On
dit c'est vrai et puis après qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ? Rien.
Absolument rien.
Alors que le problème, il est très
grave. Mais
mais et je vais vous donner un autre
exemple. On vient de sortir des
statistiques dites et enfin en partie
hein,
sur les élèves, les l'origine des élèves
dans les dans les grandes dans les grand
dans une certain nombre de grandes
villes de de France. On s'aperçoit qu'on
est à 40 45 50 % d'élèves issus de la
population immigrée
légal, illégale et autres hein.
Donc des Français
mais bien sûr. Bon on le constate et
maintenant on voit que ça fait 2 ans que
cette étude est sortie mais maintenant
elle est publiée maintenant mais elle
est sortie avant qui est sorti l'étude
c'est France
stratégie.
France stratégie. Oui France Stratégie.
Et bien ce qui est intéressant de voir
c'est que on a sorti ça. Quelles sont
les réactions que ça amène ? Parce que
il suffit vous, moi, n'importequel
d'entre nous, si on dit bon, il y a 50 %
des élèves dans telle ville qui sont des
élèves venus, on sait ce que ça veut
dire. Ça veut dire qu'il y a un problème
de langue puisque chez nous on n'impose
pas la pratique de la langue pour être
reconnu français hein alors qu'on
devrait le faire comme les Américains,
comme les Anglais ou d'autres hein. Bon,
il y a la pratique de la langue, il y a
l'environnement parce que quand on est
dans un dans un environnement de les
comme souvent ces pauvres gens parce que
la plupart d'entre eux sont des pauvres
gens hein, comment voulez-vous que les
gosses ils travaillent à la maison ?
C'est pas vrai. Ça veut dire que par
exemple, moi je me souviens quand on
était tout jeune, on avait des cours,
après les cours, on avait des séances
avec des surveillants et on continuait à
travailler
étude.
Exactement les études. Et on faisait ces
études, on va les études à l'école. Bon,
pourquoi aujourd'hui on le fait pas ? Et
oui, pourquoi on ne réhabilite pas le
système des études pour justement hein
amener tous ces gens à pouvoir
travailler dans de meilleures conditions
que chez eux ?
Protégés par la République.
Protégé par la République. Et là, la
République joue son rôle. Mais la
République, elle veut pas ça parce que
la République, elle suit les réactions
des syndicats des syndicats hein et des
fédérations de parents d'élèves plus ou
moins manipulés. Et du même coup et ben
on ne fait rien, on ne fait rien de
sérieux. Et ben ça c'est alors si je
prends ça mais je pourrais vous citer
plein d'exemples dans plein de domaines.
C'est là où on voit que c'est en train
de ça va mal et et que il faut à un
moment donné pour s'en sortir bah il
faut quand même faire un tour de vis si
vous voulez.
Alors je vais prendre votre raisonnement
et je vais parler de la guerre contre le
climat du réchauffement climatique.
Oui bien sûr.
Alors on fait quoi ? On fait une bonne
dictature verte. On supprime tous les
vieux boomers. On on impose très
fortement les choses. On fait quoi ?
Est-ce que l'acceptation n'est pas plus
forte que la dictature ?
Alors, je crois qu'il y a je pense qu'il
faut poser le problème différemment de
la manière dont il est posé aujourd'hui.
Si je peux me permettre,
nous ne savons pas en réalité, nous ne
savons pas quelle est la part.
Oh ben non, on sait très bien là. Non,
attendez, attends. Non, non, c'est pas
vrai parce qu'il y a les cycles de
Condratief et de Milancovic, si vous
voulez vérifier qui font que dans les
selon les centaines ou les milliers
d'années, on est plus chaud ou moins
chaud.
Or, nous y sommes comme nous sommes dans
le reste. La question c'est quelle est
la part des individus ? Moi je dis pas
qu'il y a pas un réchauffement et je ne
dis pas que nous ne sommes pas
coupables. Je dis quelle est la part
réelle du réchauffement climatique dû
aux individus. Elle est énorme, j'en
suis convaincu. Il y a pas qu'elle. Et
quelle est la part qui vient de
d'éléments que nous ne maîtrisons pas ?
Pourquoi je dis ça ? C'est parce que de
dire "On va lutter contre les mauvaises
habitudes des gens pour régler le
problème", c'est nécessaire mais
insuffisant.
Parce qu'il faut aussi se dire puisque
quoi qu'il arrive, il va y avoir une
évolution climatique vers des la forte
chaleur, comment l'être humain va-t-il
pouvoir s'adapter et qu'est-ce que nous
devons faire pour qu'il puisse s'adapter
? Donc il s'agit pas de dire on va faire
de la décroissance et puis et puis on va
manger que des trucs. Non, il s'agit de
dire est-ce que l'être humain est
capable de supporter des températures
moyennes au lieu de 20° mettant ou de
18°gr de passer à 23 ou 24, ce qui est
peut dire 45 en plein été.
Est-ce que l'individu est capable de
boire moins hein et s'habituer comme les
toir à sucer des cailloux ? Ah oui, mais
on n'est pas prêt ici he quand je vois
les bars et les cafés, on n'est pas
prêt. On n'est pas prêt d'arriver là
hein.
Non mais on commence déjà à sucer des
cailloux.
Bon oui, ça c'est vrai hein. On peut
est-ce que par est-ce qu'il faut prendre
est-ce qu'il faut encourager un système
de production agricole adapté ? Donc il
faut qu'on travaille sur les semences et
sur tout ça pour modifier pour qu'elle
puisse se développer avec moins d'eau et
plus de chaleur. Où est-ce qu'il faut
envoyer des centres de production de
différents produits beaucoup plus au
nord ? Je pense au vignoble en
particulier hein. Le vin à partir du
moment où il sera à 15 ou 16°gr, il sera
imbuvable. Bon, du coup, les Anglais
maintenant et puis d'autres les
Allemands disent "On va planter du vin
parce que les vignobles parce que nous
on aura du vin formidable alors que
l'Espagne, l'Italie, les sud de la
France, ils vont souffrir." Oui, mais
c'est tout ça qu'il faut penser. Or, je
constate qu'aujourd'hui, on ne
s'intéresse exclusivement qu'à dire il
faut diminuer, il faut reconstituer la
couche d'ozone. Donc, il faut diminuer à
Paris, on va rouler à 30 à l'heure et on
va sauver la on va sauver le monde.
Forcellement, ça me fait c'est un petit
truc mais il faut pas faire d'un petit
truc la solution de tout. Il faut rester
raisonnable.
Donc question internet, nos gouvernants
actuels ont-ils une vision d'avenir ou
pensent-ils uniquement à la prochaine à
la prochaine élection ?
Je crois que le gouvernant vous savez
alors je vais vous dire moi j'ai
toujours dit dit j'étais convaincu de du
chose c'est que dans les entreprises
modernes les grandes entreprises
modernes 99,9 % des patrons ne pensent
qu' au résultat de fin d'année parce
qu'en général ils en tireront quelques
profits hein au ou à l'évolution du
cours de bourse là c'est tous les 3 mois
parce que ils jouent ils jouent leur
avenir puisque si le bourse tombe eux
tombent aussi. Bon, chez les politiques,
c'est la même chose. Les politiques ont
comme horizon les élections. On sait
très bien, hein. Aujourd'hui, par
exemple, on nous dit la dette, on le
quoi qu'il en coûte, c'est je dépense,
je dépense. OK. Formidable, hein. Ça
c'est sûr que on dépense quand
c'est pas ton argent,
hein.
Surtout quand c'est pas ton argent.
Exactement. Mais de toute manière, comme
quoi qu'on raconte, il va bien falloir
le payer sous une forme ou sous une
autre, hein. Ben, personne ne voudra en
parler avant l'élection présidentielle,
mais moi, je peux prendre un pari tout
de suite. C'est dans les de mois qui
suivront l'élection, vous allez voir ce
qui va arriver, quel que soit celui qui
celui ou celle qui sera élu, parce qu'il
n'y aura pas le choix.
Parce qu'il n'y aura pas le choix.
Quand vous êtes endetté
de manière impressionnante, que
l'inflation remonte peu à peu et ben bah
et comme il faut payer ses dettes, quoi
qu'on vous raconte et ben on sortira
pas.
Revenons à à notre beau pays, la France.
Euh
quel Donnez-moi deux actions à prendre
tout de suite pour améliorer le
quotidien des Français. [soupir]
Alors, ça peut être des actions
personnelles.
Ah, mais moi je veux dire d'abord, il y
en a une, c'est
donner un obje Alors, ça c'est clair,
c'est donner un objectif pour restaurer
la confiance. [souffle coupé]
Le chef, la force du chef, disait tout à
l'heure, c'est c'est une vision.
C'est-à-dire le chef, lui, il a une
vision de l'avenir et il va mobiliser
tout le monde sur une vision de
l'avenir. Souvenez-vous de Kennedy ?
Vous savez, Kennedy quand il a pris le
pouvoir aux États-Unis, hein, c'était
une catastrophe. Les Russes venaient
d'envoyer la chienne Laica dans
l'espace. Ils avaient envoyé, ils
envoyaient satellite, ça marchait très
bien. Ils se préparaient à envoyer
Gagarine et de l'autre côté, il y avait
les Américains qui avaient envoyer dans
une fusée qui s'appelait Vanguard un
espèce de pamplemousse qui faisait 5 kg
et elle avait explosé à 150 km
d'altitude. Donc la l'Amérique qui avait
gagné la guerre était humiliée face à
l'époque à l'Union Soviétique.
Qu'est-ce qu' a fait Kennedy ? On peut
critiquer beaucoup Kennedy sur beaucoup
de choses. Dieu sait si on peut. Mais il
a eu un coup de génie.
C'est quand il a vu ça, il a vu que
l'Amérique était désespérée, humilié,
n'y croyait plus. En plus, il avait
plein de problèmes avec leur leur au
niveau extérieur.
Il a dit à l'Amérique, "Dans 10 ans,
nous serons sur la Lune."
Et en 10 ans, dans 10 ans, sera sur la
Lune. Il fixait un objectif à toute
l'Amérique en disant "On se retrouche
les manches, on est capable, on va y
arriver parce qu'on est les plus forts.
Si on fait pas de bêtises, dans 10 ans,
on sera sur la Lune." Et entre
parenthèses 10 ans après en prenant des
risques insensés, jamais aucun pays
aujourd'hui n'enverrait des gars dans la
sur la Lune comme on a envoyé les trois
Américains à l'époque hein. C'est
d'ailleurs, il fallait du courage pour
le faire hein parce que les types et les
gars aussi parce qu'ils ont pris des
risques insensés hein. Ils avaient plus
de chance de rester sur place hein que
de que de revenir que de revenir. Mais
il a réussi, il a remotivé l'Amérique.
Parce que quand vous donnez un but et
que les gens se mobilisent autour de ce
but, ça crée tous les tout le monde le
sait, ça crée un phénomène d'espérance.
Les gens ont confiance dans l'avenir
parce qu'ils ont l'espérance. Ils
sentent qu'ils peuvent y arriver.
L'action sort du rêve.
Exactement. Saintx Péri qui disait ça,
hein.
Le reniement de Saint-Pierre aussi.
Mais oui, aussi. Mais oui, mais c'est
vrai vous et c'est ça donc la première
chose comme je dirais du chef quel qu'il
soit c'est de remobiliser en donnant un
objectif et un but. Alors bien sûr la
deuxième ensuite c'est montrer l'exemple
c'est-à-dire que quand on dit à des gens
voilà ce qu'on va faire il faut pas
commencer par s'arrêter en route ou se
perdre dans tous les petits chemins,
hein.
C'est votre côté militaire qui parle.
Non non parce que non parce que dans les
entreprises, j'ai vu des entreprises
gagner hein. J'ai eu la chance un moment
d'être par dans une entreprise s'appeler
Jacob Schard. C'était c'était un
allemand hein qui avait qui avait monté
cette en partant d'un petit café à
Hambourg, il avait monté le deuxième
groupe mondial de café de chocolat.
était pas mal hein, basé en Suisse. Et
il s'appelait Klaus Jacobs. Et Jacobs,
il était d'une clarté totale. Il disait
voilà, notre objectif hein, c'est ça,
c'est d'être le premier mondial et tout
l'entreprise tout le monde était
mobilisé là-dessus. D'ailleurs, à un
point où quand quelqu'un avait des
doutes, il le convoquait, il disait
"Mais attendez,
où vous croyez et on va vous aider parce
qu'on va y arriver hein ? ou si vous n'y
croyez pas, il faut pas rester chez nous
parce que toute manière nous ne sommes
là que pour ça. Donc c'était une un
c'était une une conviction très partagée
si je peux dire hey il y a plein
d'entreprises qui sont comme ça
mais à partir du moment où elles ont des
patrons qui sont des visionnaires.
Michelin était un visionnaire, c'est pas
un militaire, c'est un visionnaire
Michelin. Il a fait de sa boîte une
sacrée boîte.
Macron c'est un visionnaire ou pas ?
Je pense pas.
Qui qui dans la classe politique, la
pauvreté de la classe politique, qui est
visionnaire dans la classe politique
française ?
Ben ce que je regrette aujourd'hui,
c'est que justement je trouve je trouve
que pour le moment, en tout cas, on va
voir avec la campagne, mais pour le
moment je ne vois pas de politique quel
de tout bord qu'il soit hein, qu'il soit
un visionnaire. On a eu le président
Mitrand était un visionnaire dans son
euh Michel Rocard était un visionnaire
hein. Euh je parlais de Pompidou tout à
l'heure, c'était un visionnaire. Ils
avaient ils avaient Giscar avec ses
comme il était qu'il était c'était un
visionnaire dans son avec ses idées.
C'était des gens qui étaient qui avait
un mobile qui les poussait vers quelque
chose et qui savaient le transmettre à
tout le monde. Voyez
euh le problème là c'est que
ben on cherche et on voit pas
grand-chose qui nous annonce là où on va
aller et là où on doit aller. Si si on
n' plus de chef, si on n' pas de chef à
disp à disposition, est-ce que notre
armée va nous aider à votre avis ?
Est-ce qu'il y a des leaders encore dans
notre armée ou est-ce que c'est
les militaires sont sont on a on a
d'excellents quelques-uns des chefs de
l'armée actuelle qui sont excellents.
D'utant plus qu'ils ont fait leur preuve
non seulement dans les bureaux mais au
feu enfin au combat hein. Ce qui a une
époque était pas le cas chez nous hein.
Là maintenant on a des gens qui
effectivement se sont battus dans les
différents théâtres d'opération et qui
ont grimpé les échelons et qui sont
maintenant des les chefs de l'armée. Je
crois qu'ils connaissent très bien leur
métier, mais il faut pas confondre
le militaire avec son système, son
organisation, hein, avec le civil. Il
faut pas confondre le militaire avec le
politique. D'ailleurs, regardez, quand
les militaires prennent leur retraite et
se reconvertissent dans le civil, il y
en a pas beaucoup qui s'en sortent et
pourtant ils sont très brillants. Mais
ils ont du mal à s'adapter à un mode de
vie, à un mode d'expression, un mode de
raisonnement qui est pas le leur hein.
Ça ne veut pas dire qu'ils sont mauvais
ou bons. Ça veut dire que c'est autre
chose.
Voilà. Et je pense que et au niveau du
politique, je pense qu'alors là le
politique en France en particulier euh
pour de multiples raisons, le politique
est englué
dans des doctrines du passé et n'a pas
été capable de se de se faire sa propre
révolution pour imaginer l'avenir,
hein. Et et aujourd'hui, les politiques
sont la plupart des politiques, faut
bien le dire, vivent au jour le jour au
gré des sondages.
Bon, élargissons un peu le domaine. La
Chine, la Russie, l'Inde, le Pakistan,
on en fait quoi ?
Bah, le Pakistan se rapproche de la
Chine bien sûr pour se défendre. Comme
le Pakistan est à côté de l'Afghanistan,
entre parenthèses, on voit que là, ils
sont en train de se faire quelque chose
et sachant que de l'autre côté, il y a
l'Iran. Donc là, il y a il va se passer
quelque chose, quelque chose
d'intéressant de construction, hein.
L'Inde, ben l'Amérique aujourd'hui
essaie de se rapprocher, l'États-Unis
essaie de se rapprocher de l'Inde.
Marche forcée, hein, ils veulent
vraiment se rapprocher de l'Inde.
Pourquoi ? parce que c'est le seul pays
qui reste en Asie qui est capable de
tenir tête à la Chine parce qu'en 2000
aux environs de 2050, ça devrait être le
pays le plus peuplé du monde hein. Et ça
devrait être la deuxième puissance
mondiale sur le plan économique, hein.
Les Chinois numéro 1, les Indiens numéro
2, les Américains numéro 3.
La France où
on on sera sorti des 10 premiers.
On sera sorti des 10 premiers. On perd
On perd régulièrement. On sera sorti.
On est on vient on s'est fait passer
justement par l'Inde, mais l'Inde, elle
grimpe et nous on descend. Donc c'est ça
va être catastrophique pour le pays.
Bah c'estàd que il faut qu'on trouve il
faut qu'on trouve des ressources mais
justement il faut qu'on change de
stratégie de politique pour admettre que
nous ne sommes plus la grande puissance
qu'on a été, qu'on [grognement] a des
points forts et il faut comme on dit
dans dans les dans les affaires hein, il
faut apprendre à capitaliser sur nos
points forts à fond hein et à par contre
essayer d'évacuer les points faibles
parce que là-dessus on coule. Or, nous
nous gaspillons nos moyens aussi bien
sur le faible que sur le fort. Donc, on
se on se on perd une bonne partie de nos
capacités.
La Chine, c'est quoi avec la Chine ? La
Chine pour moi c'est ben c'est le pays
qui est qui est en train de il alors la
Chine est en train d'arriver, ils
[raclement de gorge] sont en train de
devenir la première puissance mondiale.
Les Américains, première puissance
mondiale économique, hein économique,
les Américains pensent qu'ils vont tenir
par rapport à eux, maintiendront leur
leadership par leur puissance militaire,
trois fois celle de la Chine hein et
également par leur capacité justement
sur le cyber, le cyber le cyber en
général où là ils pensent qu'ils ont
beaucoup d'avance et que les tentatives
chinoises pour récupérer du matériel
pointu et autres ont été bloquées depuis
Trump. Donc il se pensent que les
Américains pensent qu'ils vont s'en
sortir. Moi je suis pas si optimiste que
ça. Je pense que les Chinois sont
capables grâce à des volumes de
recherche d'investissement recherche
très important et à des
campagnes d'espionnage
bien ça fait partie du problème. Ils ont
des ingénieurs, ils font de la recherche
en grande quantité et ils font de
l'espionnage à grande échelle. Donc il
est évident qu'ils ont tous les éléments
pour progresser hein. C'est cinique ce
que je dis mais ils ont tous les
éléments pour progresser.
Ils ont la rage aussi.
Oui mais ils veulent il va alors ils ont
c'est alors j'allais Oui. Tout à l'heure
je vous parlais d'Espérance.
Les Chinois, la Chine, il faut pas
l'oublier, elle a été humiliée par les
occidentaux à l'époque de la guerre de
l'opium quand les Anglais ont voulu ont
voulu que la Chine achète de l'opium qui
était produite en Inde et en disant ça
fera un joli déboucher pour nous. Bon,
le problème de l'opium c'était que ça ça
a mis en l'air la population hein et les
Chinois l'ont payé très cher. Donc les
Chinois, ils l'ont pas oublié et ils ont
qu'une idée, c'est redevenir la première
puissance mondiale. Donc là,
l'espérance, eux, ils l'ont dans ce
sens-là. Même les plus opposants au
régime, tous ont envie que la Chine
redevienne la première puissance
mondiale comme elle était dans les
années 1700.
Alors ça pose un du coup, je pense
qu'ils ont une motivation très forte.
Et les Américains eux ils essaient de
mettre des parfeux. Mais est-ce qu'avec
des parfeux on peut arrêter tout le
temps ? À un moment les parfeux cèdent
hein. Si vousz face à la marée, vous
mettez des digues, mais à partir du
moment la marée devient trop grosse,
elle passe par-dessus la digue. C'est un
vieux principe de nature hein écologique
hein. Le don je crois que le seul risque
que nous avons vraiment c'est ce qu'on
appelle les historiens appellent le
piège de Tucidide. C'est dire que nous
avons aujourd'hui
les Américains qui dominent encore
militairement nettement
les les Chinois. Mais pour combien de
temps ? Parce que les Chinois, ils
montent très vite, ils investissent
aussi, ils apprennent et dans 15 ans,
dans 20 ans, ils vont avoir une capacité
militaire aussi forte que les
Américains. Faut pas se faire
d'illusion, hein. Regardez dans le
spatial à quelle vitesse il rattrapent
les Américains actuellement. C'est
spectaculaire hein ce qu'ils font. Il y
a pas que là hein. Donc qu'est-ce qui
peut se passer ? c'est que les
Américains voyant qu'il risquent de
perdre le leadership décident de faire
la guerre contre la Chine. Le vrai
risque des 10 prochaines années parce
qu'après à mon avis après ça sera trop
tard parce que l'Amérique
même si elle est devant devra supporter
de telles pertes guerre avec la Chine
avec en plus les moyens nucléaires et
autres que elle il pourra pas prendre le
risque. Ils pourront plus prendre le
risque. Donc il y a un créneau assez
court en définitive. Et dans ce
créneau-là, qu'est-ce qui peut se passer
? Est-ce que les Américains sont prêts à
faire la guerre ? Alors Biden jure que
non, en disant "On va régler le problème
des négociations commerciales et
autres". Euh moi, j'oublie pas que
toutes les guerres aux États-Unis, elles
ont été faites par les démocrates,
jamais par les républicains,
hein. C'est les démocrates qui ont lancé
les guerres. Donc il faut faire
attention parce que c'est on on rentre
dans une période où le basculement de la
stratégie américaine tout actuel en
disant on s'occupe de la Chine et rien
que de la Chine parce que c'est ça hein.
Euh la la deuxième étape c'est est-ce
que ça va pas les amener à un moment
donné vu la perte de possibilités pour
eux à déclencher une guerre qui pourrait
être totale ou partielle ? Ça c'est on
revient là au problème de guerre. Alors
et là ça peut se faire probablement sur
la sur la mer de Chine la zone. La zone
c'est la mer de Chine.
Mer de Chine et collier de perles ou pas
?
Oui bien sûr. Bah les colliers de perles
bien sûr.
Et la Russie on en fait quoi ?
[soupir][souffle coupé]
Bah, la Russie, elle est elle est la
Russie, elle subit
elle subit une erreur stratégique de
l'Europe depuis euh les année 2000,
hein. Et là là la chanolière Merkel
après elle a pas elle a pas bien joué le
jeu par rapport à quand elle est arrivée
aussi, elle a pas elle a pas aidé
le quand le président Poutine avait dit
en tout début des années 2000 je veux me
rapprocher de l'Europe
l'on n'y a pas cru et on a subi la
pression des Américains qui évidemment
ne le voulaient pas des pays
pro-américains comme la Pologne ou les
pays de maintenant du groupe de
Visegrade qui évidemment ne voulaient
pas avoir la Russie parce qu'ils en
sortaient, on les comprend aussi. Donc
il y avait une opposition au nord et
nous on n' pas eu la force, les gens du
sud et de la moyenne Europe, on n' pas
eu la force de dire on s'en fout, on va
négocier avec les Russes pour les les
associer à nous. ce que Dogo l' appelait
la robe de l'Atlantique à l'oral hein.
Et indiscutablement
ça c'était c'était la politique à faire
parce que on mettait les Russes avec
nous, les Américains
ensuite dans un deuxième temps parce
qu'ils avaient tout ils ont toujours eu
peur de ça. Ils ont toujours eu peur de
cette de ce rapprochement russo-européen
qui ferait de son ensemble un groupe
plus puissant que les États-Unis sur le
plan d'ensemble. hein, faut pas
l'oublier hein, à cause la Russie
amenant les énergies et nous amenant
tout le reste. Donc, on pouvait arriver
à faire quelque chose de très fort.
Donc, les Américains ont dans un
deuxième temps ont créé des pôles de de
déstabilisation en Europe pour empêcher
qu'il y a des rapprochements. Le plus le
majeur, c'est l'Ukraine. L'Ukraine a été
montée pour justement créer une
opposition, un foyer d'opposition dans
la durée entre l'Europe et et les
Russes. Donc ça ça a été une
avec tout ça les Russes ont été séparés
et d'un autre côté avec les sanctions
que nous avons prises en Europe en
particulier ben qu'est-ce qu'on a fait ?
On a poussé les Russes vers les Chinois.
Alors maintenant et ce qui apparaît
c'est que la discussion semble-t-il à
ils en ont parlé à
à Genève quand le président Poutine a
rencontré le président Biden. Le
problème maintenant pour les Américains,
c'est d'empêcher que les Russes aillent
trop loin avec la Chine.
Et le problème de Poutine, c'est qu'il
voit les Chinois arriver en masse en
Sibérie parce que les salaires sont plus
élevés qu'en Chine, hein. Et donc, il y
a une colonisation actuellement de la
Sibérie Chinois. Or, si on dit
colonisation, à un moment donné, les
Chinois peuvent dire "Mais il y a plus
de Chinois qu'au en Sibérie, donc c'est
pour nous et c'est les zones
énergiques." Donc là, il y a une
stratégie où la la Moscou a absolument
besoin de se protéger et il a besoin des
occidentaux indiscutablement pour
justement faire face, hein, et alors que
les occidentaux l'ont poussé dans les
bras des Chinois.
Question internet. L'austérité c'est un
modèle tenable pour la France. Question.
Aucun investissement dans l'éducation,
dans notre recherche, dans notre
technologie, aucune défense de nos
industries. Il rajoute un PS : "Je ne
savais pas que Bouge Pérefis était
démocrate. Guerre du golf, guerre
d'Irak."
Oui. Oui. Pour Bush, oui, mais attendez,
Bush c'était effectivement mais oui,
c'est vrai. Pour Bush, c'est vrai, vous
avez raison. Bou était pas démocrate.
Mais
le reste est vrai.
Le reste est vrai. Il peut vérifier. Le
reste est vrai. Et même d'avant même
d'avant
l'austérité.
Pardon ?
L'austérité. Alors,
le sérité n'est pas une solution en soi.
On fait pas vivre des gens en les
mettant au régime. Au bout d'un certain
temps, les gens ils font péter le régime
et puis c'est normal, hein. J'en suis
une brillante démonstration mais hein.
Le le non le sérité ça peut se concevoir
pour un temps réduit à partir du moment
où on a des objectifs derrière. mais des
objectifs que l'on tient. Le drame
actuel, c'est que dans notre pays, on ne
croit plus les annonces qui sont faites
dans tous les domaines. On vous annonce
demain, il va on va faire ça, personne y
croit.
Et je dirais et même quand c'est vrai,
les gens disent ça c'est qu'ils l'ont
fait, c'est qu'il y a eu quelque chose
et ben c'est pas on nous cache quelque
chose. En définitive le
il y a le problème c'est le manque c'est
le manque de croyance de confiance.
C'est un problème de confiance.
Comment on rétablit la confiance ?
Par l'espérance et par les objectifs. Je
reviens à ce que tout à l'heure la part
de rêve.
Il faut faire rêver les gens pour les
mobiliser.
Comment on va les faire rêver ? On a un
réchauffement climatique qui va nous
envoyer dans le mur. On a un système
financier qui tient juste par des effets
de manche. On a une une classe politique
européenne qui est en décrépitude
totale. On va avoir des tensions sur nos
approvisionnements en eau, en énergie,
en alimentation. Hm.
On va avoir une augmentation des
communautaristes, on va avoir une
augmentation des gens qui se
qui s'indigne pour tout un tas de
choses. Ça va devenir complètement
ingouvernable. On va se retrouver avec
quoi ? Une dictature ? On va se
retrouver avec quoi ? Même même le
chaos.
Non, je crois qu'il enfin il faut pas
souhaiter la dictature bien entendu
parce que c'est la dictature sont
toujours des des moments très durs à
vivre pour les pour les gens qui sont
soumis bien entendu et c'est pas ça pas
toujours très bien c'est moins qu'on
puisse dire mais [raclement de gorge] ce
que je crois quand même c'est que
dans la vie il faut toujours avoir une
l'espoir c'estàd qu'il faut pas certes
quand on voit la longue énumération qui
vient d'être faite
non exhaustive.
Oui, non exhaustive, hein. On se dit là,
on est vraiment mal parti. Oui, mais
n'empêche qu'il y a toujours il y a
toujours quelque chose.
Il y a toujours quelque chose qui permet
de s'en sortir. Il y a toujours quelque
chose qui se passe. Il faut avoir
confiance dans l'avenir et il faut il
faut y croire. Il faut se dire "Mais
non, mais il va si on si on y est si on
le fait, on fait ce qu'il faut. Si on
bouge, on va trouver des solutions, on
va s'améliorer.
Vous savez quand Elon Musk dit bon
l'Europe enfin le pardon le monde est en
train de monter en température, bah pas
de problème, on verra les gens sur Mars.
[grognement] C'est une forme d'espoir.
Bon, personne n'y croit pour le moment.
Mégalomanie,
hein
ou de mégalomanie.
Oui, mais ça c'est les deux d'ailleurs
hein, probablement les deux. Mais si un
jour il envoie des gens là-bas et qu'on
s'aperçoit au bout de quelques années
quand même que les gens là-bas ça se
passe bien, ben ça fera réfléchir. Vous
êtes d'accord avec moi ? Bon, on est pas
là.
Ça se passera pas bien parce qu'il y a
pas de champ magnétique.
Non mais je suis Attendez, je vous dis
pas, je dis c'est c'est avec des silles
hein parce que bon, personnellement, je
suis loin d'être convaincu que ça soit
sérieux hein. Donc c'est pas ça.
Je mets j'ouvre une parenthèse. On va
parler de notre ami Jacques Blamont. Feu
Jacques Blamont. Oui.
Et il nous disait toujours envoyer des
hommes dans l'espace, ça sert à rien. Il
faut envoyer des robots.
Oui,
ça coûte moins cher, c'est plus facile,
c'est plus efficace.
Rayonnement,
bien sûr. Mais bien entendu.
Mais il disait il me disait envoyer des
hommes dans l'espace rêver et les
politiques, ils aiment bien.
Ben oui, mais mais on mais on revient la
même chose. Il est évident, regardez,
c'est comme les avions de chasse. On
nous on s'obstine à vouloir faire des
avions de chasse pilotés. Bon, quand on
voit l'évolution avec les drones dans
tous les domaines, il est évident que
l'avion de chasse, on nous en parle, on
nous en parle et on nous en reparle,
mais l'avenir c'est pas l'avion de
chasse piloté par un, c'est le drone
parce que le drone n'a pas les limites
de résistance qu' résistance qu'à l'être
humain. L'être humain, il est beaucoup
moins résistant qu'un drone. Donc, il
est moins efficace une fois qu'on est
capable de piloter le drone avec tous
les éléments du problème. Donc oui, il
faut repenser.
Mais mais ce que vous dites le moi il me
semble que il y a il y a de l'espoir si
vous voulez. On peut vivre avec regardez
on dit la température va monter à 45°gr.
OK, je vous disais tout à l'heure, il y
a ceux qui disent "Ou là là, il y a
qu'une solution, c'est partir." Mais il
y a d'autres qui vont dire "Non, il y a
peut-être une autre solution, c'est
d'imaginer des cités dans lesquelles les
gens vivront et dans lequel la
température sera acceptable durant
l'été." Seulement, comment on va
financer ça ? Et comment ça va
fonctionner ? Est-ce que alors et là, on
revient ce problème. Est-ce que c'est
alors avec du nucléaire, hein ? Est-ce
que c'est avec de l'hydrogène ? parce
que on n parle pas mais l'avenir c'est
pas l'électrique. L'électrique c'est une
fumisterie. C'est plus polluvant. C'est
aussi polluvant. Si c'est pas plus
polluvant que avec tous les déchets et
tout et l'extraction que que ce qu'on
fait avec les énergies fossiles.
Ça délocalise la pollution. C'est bien
pour les politiques.
Ouais. Mais voilà. Mais le mais le vrai
problème c'est l'hydrogène pour les
voitures en particulier. Qu'est-ce qui
va se passer quand les Chinois qui ont
mis le cap sur l'hydrogène dans 5 ans,
les premières voitures à hydrogène vont
sortir en Chine. Qu'est-ce qui va se
passer quandir qu'elles sont pas
polluantes du tout, que ça sera efficace
et tout ? Bah évidemment, ils vont
conquérir le marché mondial he ça
prendra 5 ans, 10 ans, 15 ans. Mais vous
allez voir. Bon, mais c'est ça les
réponses. Les réponses que je vous
disais tout à l'heure, c'est que au lieu
de dire c'est une catastrophe, il nous
reste plus qu'une chose, c'est remplacer
nos tout ce qu'on boit par de l'eau,
hein. Enfin, la petite la petite danoise
suédoise, pardon.
Oui. Non, norvégienne. Greta.
Greta. Greta. La petite Greta. Bon, mais
c'est pas ça la solution. La solution
c'est pas bien sûr qu'il faut apprendre
à se limiter et tout mais c'est mais
c'est pas le fond du problème. Le fond
du problème c'est réfléchissons à
comment nous pouvons vivre
convenablement dans un monde qui aura 5
ou 10 degrés de plus.
Ça ça c'est un problème intéressant et
sur lequel tous les grands esprits de la
planète s'y réfléchissent trouveront des
réponses hein.
En espérant que ce soit pas déjà trop
tard.
Ah bah oui mais c'est le problème c'est
que plus le temps passe et plus ça va
mal. l'horloge tourne.
Et oui, parce qu'on parce qu'on confond
l'immédiat
avec le long terme une fois de plus. On
est comme pour les élections, on est
comme pour tout le reste. On est dans
l'immédiat comme dans les entreprises
hein. On ne regarde que bout de son nez
et on ne veut pas essayer de voir, avoir
une vision à moyen et long terme et
ensuite de mettre le cap sur cette
vision en mobilisant toutes les bonnes
volontés. Quel regard quel Quel regard
vous avez sur nos services de
renseignement intérieur comme extérieur
sur des questions de terrorisme, de
renseignement économique ? Est-ce que
nos services se sont pas un peu
empattés, ronronnés ? Est-ce qu'on a pas
des services qui ont perdu leur
agressivité ? Est-ce que notre pointe de
diamant ne s'est pas émoussée ?
Bon, je dis moi je dirais plutôt que
tous les services se sont émoussés
parce que dans là comme ailleurs,
il y a une certaine routine des esprits
qui est rentré dans le système
et qui fait que
on voit bien les interprétations qui ont
été faites dans les années précédentes
d'un certain nombre de problèmes
complexes
sur le terrorisme, sur les pays en en
guerre. type Syrie, Libye ou ce que vous
voudrez ou Afrique ou le Sahel. On voit
bien que les interprétations qui ont été
faites, enfin du moins les décisions
prises par les dirigeants ont été des
décisions erronées. Si les ministres et
les dirigeants prennent des décisions
erronées, c'est parce qu'ils ont de
mauvaises informations. Donc on peut en
conclure que effectivement les services,
quand je parle de là la France, mais il
y a d'autres pays que la France, hein.
d'autres les il y a eu il y a
probablement une perte de d'acuité
dans les analyse
qui peut venir peut-être aussi d'une
perte d'intuition, c'est-à-dire que on
travaille avec des données de plus en
plus grand en plus en plus grand nombre
le big data.
Alors le problème du big data, c'est que
d'un côté effectivement on comprend
mieux et on va plus loin, mais d'un
autre côté on moyennise.
Et la moyennis vous fait passer à côté
des éléments vraiment spécifiques si
vous voulez hein. Donc c'est pour ça que
je dis probablement on a perdu
l'intuition
et ça c'est pour moi alors ça c'est le
premier le point sur le plan de la lutte
antiterrorisme. les je pense que les les
services ont fait ce qu'ils devaient
faire et surtout il y a un point qui a
été très positif dans les 20 dernières
années, ça a été le la le développement
de la collaboration entre tous les
services sur les problèmes de terrorisme
parce que c'est sûr que comme chacun
était menacé hein, ben chacun a voulu
travailler avec l'autre. Donc là, il y a
eu de gros progrès sur le plan de la
lutte antiterroriste parce que on a
mieux compris les mécanismes et on a
échangé les informations.
Le problème c'est que là aussi et c'est
ce qui se passe aussi d'ailleurs dans à
l'intérieur dans le problème des
banlieux et autres, le problème c'est
que on regarde des événements,
on essaie d'empêcher un événement mais
en même temps on essaie pas de répondre
au problème de fond qui a amené à cet
événement
si vous voulez. C'est ça le truc. C'est
un peu ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure. Si j'ai une classe dans
laquelle les gens parlent pas le
français et n'ont pas les moyens de
faire des études, bah il faut que je
traite ce problème en priorité, sinon ça
ne marchera pas. et ceux qui sont ce
qu'on se considéront à ce moment-là
comme des exclus avec toutes les
conséquences que ça aura le dans je
crois que c'est ça hein si les gens sont
partis fascinerés alors faut pas oublier
hein on a accusé les jeunes des banlieux
d'être partis en Syrie mais on oublie
trop souvent qu'en 36 37 les communistes
chez nous sont partis en Espagne et pas
que des communistes he des rêveurs, des
aventuriers des gens qui avaient envie
de vivre une aventure.
sont partis en Espagne hein pour faire
la guerre avec les Républicains. Donc je
vous dis à chaque à chaque étape, à
chaque période hein dans l'histoire, il
y a comme ça une attractivité qui se
crée hein. Le problème c'est qu'il faut
y apporter l'état de y apporter le plus
vite possible des réponses efficaces
pour y mettre un terme sinon c'est une
dérive qui se prolonge dans le temps.
Question internet. Avons-nous
suffisamment de recul pour comprendre
quel est le rapport d'Emmanuel Macron au
service de renseignement ? Entre
parenthèses, méfiance, complicité,
purure vision comptable ? Fermez la
parenthèse. Ou bien faudra-t-il attendre
à minima pour cela ?
Ah non, ben je pense que le président de
la République, il il a d'abord il a à
côté de lui, il a un coordinateur
national du renseignement, hein. Euh il
a des patrons du renseignement, hein, du
renseignement intérieur et du
renseignement extérieur.
Euh donc je crois qu'il a ils ont ils
ont un certain nombre de choses et je
crois que je crois qu'il a il a les il a
un certain nombre d'informations. La
question qu'on peut se poser, c'est
est-ce que
le président et son équipe, parce qu'il
est pas tout seul, est-ce que les
ministres ont prennent véritablement en
compte les informations
réelles sur la situation sur les
différents terrains ou alors ou pas ?
Quand pour c'est clair quand on quand on
voit le souhait par exemple de du
ministre la phase étrangère sur
l'Afghanistan qui dit je souhaite un
gouvernement inclusif bon
hein ou le Drillant oui
c'est un certainement un excellent
ministre mais visiblement là il avait
pas compris la situation
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire voyez
donc la question c'est effectivement
est-ce que et ça c'est le problème des
services de renseignement
Est-ce que les services de renseignement
fournissent des notes qui ne font pas
plaisir mais qui représentent la réalité
ou est-ce qu'ils font des notes qui font
plaisir mais qui sont très éloignés de
la réalité ?
On appelle ça une note comment ? Une
note pas de couille, pas d'embrouille.
Oui, on veut. [rires]
Question d'internet. Les services étant
de plus en plus contraints par des
aspects techniques et réglementaires
quittent des entreprises privées qui les
outillent. entre parenthèses Google,
Palir, Amazon. Faut-il les mettre au pas
? Faut-il se contenter d'être des ravis
des progrès qu'elle permettent, des
échanges internationaux qu'elle
permettent ?
Non, je crois je crois que on a
les enfin
les sociétés, il y a des aujourd'hui
dans le monde occidental mais de l'autre
côté aussi hein, d'un côté chinois c'est
pareil. Il y a des sociétés très
puissantes qui sont devenues très
puissantes dans le cyberespace, hein.
Bon, les gars femmes, chez nous, c'est
les gars femmes. Bon, et euh qui font un
peu ce qu'elles veulent, c'est
indiscutable.
L'État, les États essaient de les mettre
au pli, [grognement] il n'y arrivent
pas. Bien entendu, on arrive à donner à
mettre des pansements sur une jambe de
bois, mais enfin c'est pas ça ne va pas
changer le fond.
Où il les utilise ? Oui oui. Ou alors où
il les utilise, c'est les cascad des
Américains en particulier, hein. Donc
évidemment, puis utilisent, ils ont pas
trop leur taper dessus quand même parce
que ça rend bien service hein. Alors
nous chez nous, le problème est un peu
différent parce que il y a un il y a un
problème qui est euh aux États-Unis qui
est très fort et qui n'existe pas chez
nous, c'est le patriotisme.
Chez les Américains, il ne viendra à
l'idée d'aucune
ni de la justice, ni des médias et
autres, hein, d'attaquer une société
parce qu'elle travaille dans l'intérêt
américain avec les services.
En France, c'est exactement le
contraire.
Regardez l'affaire la farge. C'est très
intéressant l'affaire la farge,
hein.
Poursuivie pour complicité. Oui. Alors,
je précise, voilà faire la farche. C'est
en Syrie, pendant la guerre en Syrie, il
y avait une usine de ciment français qui
était un peu au cœur du pain dans une
zone du pays s'éloigner. Il y aurait des
zones très habitables qui faisaient du
ciment. C'est qui permettaient de faire
du ciment. Bon et quand il y a eu la
guerre en Syrie entre Daesh et l'armée
syrienne, euh cette usine a continué à
travailler, hein. Et elle alors elle a
été accusée euh par les ONG, hein, en
l'occurrence d'avoir payé Daesh pour
assurer la sécurité de son personnel
pour qu'il puisse venir travailler à
l'usine. Ça c'est la version qui fait
que on démolit la société et on la on
veut la traduire pour crime contre
l'humanité. Il y a de nouveau la relance
du procès la cour d'appel avait classé
la Cour de cassation a réouvert le
dossier pour les faire condamner. OK.
Ce qu'on ne dit pas c'est tout le monde
sait que [grognement] cette usine a
servi de base aux forces spéciales qui
étaient donc à l'intérieur du dispositif
ennemi pour pouvoir rayonner.
Tout le monde le sait, on le sait pour
les Français et on pense qu'il y avait
aussi les Américains enfin spéciales
américaines. Bon, donc on est en train
de condamner du point de vue civil une
société dans un aspect civil évidemment
très très mal, très mauvais puisqu'il a
payé l'autre mais sans regarder l'autre
aspect dans lequel au contraire il
s'agissait de l'intérêt national et de
la protection de nos soldats et de la
conduite de la guerre.
Bon moi voyez alors aux États-Unis ça
c'est impensable
chez nous regardez ce qui se passe.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Est-ce que vous avez trois bouquins à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Trois livres.
Bah il y en a un d'abord parce que je
pense que avec tout ce que je vous ai
dit ce soir, il faut le relire. C'est le
petit prince
de Saint Exupér
pour rêver.
Hm.
Ça c'est pour moi c'est je pense que
c'est c'est important parce que pour
retrouver l'espoir, pour retrouver
l'enthousiasme, il faut être capable de
rêver. Il faut imaginer que notre
avenir, il peut être pas si mauvais que
ça et qu'il faut arrêter de voir tout en
catastrophe. Nous ne sommes pas la
veille d'un nouveau déluge. On a une
évolution grave et qui évolue.
Réfléchissons aux solutions pour nous en
sortir et pas exclusivement hein en
défensif. Soyons offensif. Voyez ça
c'est pour moi. Donc le le petit prince
le premier
euh
le deuxème puisqu'on a commencé par
l'Afghanistan.
Il y a plusieurs livres sont sortis sur
l'Afghanistan, mais il y en a il y en a
un des Français d'un français d'un
ambassadeur français qui s'appelle le
dîner des Talibans.
Et puisqu'on a parlé de l'Afghanistan,
je conseille à beaucoup de le lire pour
une raison très simple, c'est qu'il
explique beaucoup de choses et qu'on
voit donc les Français à un certain
niveau en tout cas à un certain moment
avaient très bien compris ce qui se
passait,
hein, et que cette guerre là, on
comprenait très bien que bon, c'est une
guerre qu'on ne pouvait que perdre.
Oui, mais c'est important hein. Bon, le
troisème, ben je pense que là c'est
carrément c'est il faut il faut lire
aujourd'hui parce que on est obligé de
regarder les rapports de force entre
tous les pays. Donc je pense qu'il faut
lire un un état du monde. Il y en a
plusieurs. Je sais pas moi, il y a la
Ramses,
mais il y en a d'autres. Iris en fait un
enf il y en a plusieurs qui paraissent.
Mais je pense qu'il faut lire un livre.
Il faut que chacun essaie de comprendre
ce qui se passe dans le monde. Pourquoi
? Parce que nous sommes nous dans un
pays qui est nombriliste à un point qui
est devenu nombriliste à un point
absolument invraisemblable.
On se regarde nombril et on s'exclame
"Qu'est-ce qu'on est beau
Bon, or c'est pas ça la vie hein. Et en
plus quand on voit ce qui se passe à
tous les pays qu'on a évoqué, les
difficultés, les guerres et tout, il
faut justement essayer de comprendre
ce qui se passe vraiment pour se dire
que nous là encore, on a été un grand
empire, nous ne sommes plus un grand
empire. On a été un empire colonial.
Nous ne sommes plus un empire colonial,
hein. Dire, on a entre parenthèses sur
le colonial, on a on en a pas parlé mais
on n pas été si mauvais que ça par
rapport à d'autres, hein. On pourrait on
pourrait on aurait pu en parler aussi.
Mais bon, le aujourd'hui he ce monde est
en train de changer. Nous nous sommes en
train de perdre des positions puisqu'on
va passer, je vous le disais, avant 2050
hein, on sera on sera sorti des 10
premières puissances mondiales. Donc
c'est très grave hein. Bon,
regardons-nous tel que nous sommes avec
nos points forts et nos points faibles.
Et là, on peut se dire ce que je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure, capitalisons sur nos
points forts. nous trouverons de
l'espoir à partir du moment, on dira
"Mais là, on est bon et ben continuons
là-dessus et mettons le paquet
là-dessus." Et puis là où on est
mauvais, ben reconnaissant qu'on est
mauvais et arrêtons de nous gargariser
en voulant croire qu'on est encore bon
sur des choses qui maintenant nous
dépassent.
Est-ce que
vous voulez qu'on utilise ça pour votre
conseil pour les jeunes générations ?
Vous avez un autre conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? croire à l'avenir.
Moi, je suis un accurable optimiste et
je pense que chacun peut trouver une
voix qui où il réussira sa vie. Chacun
peut la trouver, mais il faut de la
volonté, il faut du courage et il faut
du réalisme.
Alain Juillet, merci.
[musique]